this is jocko podcast number 279
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
helicopter blades slashed through the
hot sky
the roar of engines deafening as the
pilot twisted and turned on our final
approach
crammed into the back with my men i
tried to keep my balance
by tensing my legs and focusing my gaze
on the machine gun in the helicopter's
door
my kit was heavy on my shoulders and
sweat poured into my eyes from under the
rim of my helmet
my palms were wet as they gripped the
rifle
i pulled it closer to my chest and
prepared myself for what was to come
the airman behind the machine gun turned
to me his face was covered by a scarf
and the dark visor of his helmet but i
knew what he it meant when he held up
his
index finger i turned
and shouted to my men one minute
one minute to landing and whatever was
waiting
there for us looking into the eyes of
my young soldiers i saw steely resolve
the hardness of the paratrooper flying
into battle
i was closest to the rear door which was
now winching fully open
there was no doubt in my mind that i had
to be the first one down the ramp
i had waited years for this moment and
now was my time
i practiced it over and over again on
grass fields
in mock-up structures and on the real
things during exercises all over the
world but this was different
for the first time in my life i was
flying into war
our mission was a simple one to kill or
capture a taliban
bomb maker a bomb maker called
[ __ ] mohammed infamous for making the
improvised bombs that were responsible
for the deaths of
dozens of british and allied soldiers
we'd spent a week pouring over maps and
aerial photographs of the village
in which he was thought to live my
platoon number eight platoon
on attachment to a company of the third
battalion
of the parachute regiment was given the
honor of landing first
right in [ __ ] muhammad's back garden and
it was our task
to surround his house it was a dangerous
mission
but as the seconds counted down and i
looked out the rear of the door of the
helicopter towards the dusty plains
below
i felt a tremendous sensation of both
trepidation
and sheer excitement it was a lot of
responsibility to shoulder
but i wanted to carry it the helicopter
got closer to the ground
whipping the afghan dust into the air
until it was
a thick cloud around us ten seconds
shouted the airmen
holding tightly to a rope the door was
now fully open
the ramp hit the floor with a clunk and
a shutter went through the airframe as
the wheels touched down
everyone wobbled but kept their feet
they knew how important it was to stay
upright
and get off the heel the heli quickly
the taliban had spies everywhere scouts
that reported the movement of
helicopters
every second that we delayed d-planing
was a second for the enemy to train
their weapons
and kill those on the ramp
go go go the airmen shouted
myself and my men picking up the call so
that it rippled through the aircraft
and then we were running gritting our
teeth as though that would stop
the bullets that may await us my feet
touched down on the afghan soil
and i breathed in the dirt as i ran
through the cloud that the helicopter's
blade stirred up all around us
my rifle was up in eye level and i
looked over my sights ready to snap
shoot anyone that posed a threat to my
men
my soldiers followed me i felt like a
giant leading them from a metal beast
into the jaws of death
except that when the helicopter lifted
away and the dust settled
we were quite alone
nobody home [ __ ]
i put some of my men into defensive
positions and took others with me to
search the house
this was still a dangerous time as the
taliban were not above
booby-trapping their own homes
other than a few sacks of opium the drug
of choice
in those parts we found nothing
i walked back outside and was shrugging
off the disappointment of another quiet
mission
when a whip-like sound echoed across the
fields followed immediately by a crack
it wasn't the noise you hear in the
films it was all together
more visceral and unnerving incoming
shouted my platoon sergeant
i shouted at the men to jump into a
nearby ditch and return fire
they looked at me unbelieving it was
like being on an exercise
on salisbury plane except the noises
were not the dull simulators
we'd been accustomed to these were real
and violent somebody was shooting
with the evident intention of killing us
300 meters away i saw the enemy moving
in a line of trees
i took aim and fired
it was the start of a very long day
and that right there is an excerpt
from a book called the art of
exploration
by a former british army officer named
levison
wood who served and led combat
operations in afghanistan
but who seem to have found an equivalent
level
of excitement and danger as a writer
photographer filmmaker and explorer
and we're lucky enough to have him on
the show tonight to share
some of his experiences with us
levison thanks for coming on man thanks
for having me
that's a good way to start this thing
off brings back some memories eh
freaking good good way to kick it off
um before we jump into your
your career in the army let's let's
start at the beginning
let's start about let's talk about your
child's childhood and and you grow up
in england sure yep um stoke-on-trent
that's it not many people have heard of
it and that's that's where you actually
grew up
yeah so i i was born and raised in a
small village
um just outside of stoke on trent right
in the middle of england sort of halfway
between manchester and birmingham
kind of place that not many people sort
of travel to they just travel
past it and i think it was
it was for that reason that i was always
from a very young age curious about the
outside world i was
very keen to get away from stoke on
trent um
it will always be home but but yeah from
a from a very early age i was always
excited by the prospect of of traveling
out into the big wide world it was
something that
not many members of my family had done
um
but i always knew that there was there
was more to life than the provincial
sort of suburbs of my hometown and and
that's what inspired me
and stoke on trent that's a city where
you're
in the i guess it was prior to the pits
shutting down you were in the pits
or there's a a giant pottery factory
right
isn't it famous for making pottery soak
on trent is is the heart of the british
ceramic
industry it has been for for centuries
and um
sadly you know a lot of those um those
industries
the mines and the pottery industry died
a bit of a death through the mid 20th
century so
there was a lot of unemployment there
was a lot of poverty in stoke-on-trent
in the 80s when i grew up
and and so there weren't that many
opportunities not many people had
the opportunity to sort of travel very
much but i was very fortunate to be
to be grown up in a family of teachers
both my parents were teachers
they encouraged this spirit of curiosity
and um
you know encouraged me to to read a lot
so i read as a youngster
all about history geography travels all
those stories of
exploration of um of those very hairy
men in
the 19th century that went to the polls
you know livingston and
shackleton and scott and uh you know
those are my heroes so it was growing up
my dad read me a lot of books about
exploration lawrence of arabia people
like that
um so i think from about the age of
seven or eight i was determined to
somehow follow in their footsteps which
wasn't exactly a very realistic
uh sort of thing to to go to my careers
officer and say i want to be an explorer
but that's exactly what i did and he
sort of laughed at me and said okay well
let's see well i'm kind of thinking you
must have been even in a worse position
than me so when i was a little kid you
know i liked rock and roll music
and so when i started playing guitar and
thinking okay i'm going to write some
riffs
but it didn't take me very long to
figure out that hey all the
you know if jimmy page already wrote
that riff and tony aiomi already wrote
those riffs so what am i going to do how
am i going to write
better riffs than those guys so you had
to be even in a worse position
because the world explored yeah actually
you can make up new riffs that's
possible
but you know the most the known world
has been explored
yeah yeah so you're you're in a worse
spot than i was in
well my you know i grew up with those
stories but i was also
encouraged by stories of my grandfather
my grandad was a soldier in
um in the british army he served in
india
and burma in the far east fighting
against the japanese and
he told me these stories which felt
whilst it was still a long time ago
actually to hear them firsthand somebody
who'd been to the jungles of india who'd
been to the mountains of of of east asia
that
was like mind-blowing for me as a kid
who'd never really traveled beyond
the the confines of the united kingdom
so
that's what i wanted to do i want to go
and see not necessarily go with my pith
helmet and sort of khaki shorts and with
a big union flag but
but at the very least to go and see with
my own eyes the the kind of places that
very few people had
had traveled to um within my own so a
social circle really
so it started pretty humbly and just
going off backpacking and
you know doing what a lot of youngsters
do and um travel around the world on a
tight budget
and that was what i was determined to do
from a from a very young age
now what was your relationship with your
grandfather how long was
he still alive today no he's not so he
passed away
when i was about 18. so you know but but
growing up it was like i said it was
those those really
exciting stories and pretty gruesome
stories
like if you were in burma fighting the
japanese
good lord yeah and he was not only that
he was on pretty much one of the first
ships into japan he was part of the
occupying force in japan he was based in
hiroshima
after they dropped the a-bomb so some of
his stories were just like you know
crazy yeah and what about your dad did
your dad um
wasn't your dad in the army as well so
my dad was in the he was a reservist so
you know throughout the the 70s and 80s
um you know his period it was it was the
cold war so he
you know he he likes to tell me he was
off fighting the russians in germany you
know
it really you know realistically he was
he was out there a lot of digging
trenches on the plains of germany
but obviously no no actual fighting but
um but yeah he he always encouraged me
to
to take an interest in the military um
and um
it was things like you know he was a
cadet instructor and so on so
i remember growing up you know he'd
sometimes bring bring his rifles back
home and things like that and
as a kid he'd he'd give me a uniform and
if i was if i was a good good kid he'd
uh give me an extra stripe and
if i was naughty he'd rip one off my arm
so that's kind of that was how i grew up
yeah
and when you um were you a you're saying
that you're reading all the time
does that mean you were a good student i
was i think i
i i was always curious and and that
helps i think that's a good story you
might be the first person on the podcast
that was a good
ever had any good students on here no
everyone's everyone's just bad students
myself included so so you were
reading and you're doing pretty good in
school your parents were so both my
parents were teachers as well
yeah and one was history one was english
and and people go oh that's what and i
was like no no
i didn't do it we i didn't do any
homework
um were they teaching in your school no
they weren't was your dad teaching
you no no no so that yeah i think that
helped out i don't think i would have
liked having my teachers as
my parents as my own teachers but they
they got you on the reading path and i
think there must be something
boring like you just must have been more
naturally curious than me i was like
throwing rocks at my friends
no i did that as well yeah i mean i
think i
i was definitely a bit of a rebel and i
got into lots of trouble as a kid
i think i was just naturally um inclined
to to be curious about
history particularly and that it was it
was reading about you know
the ancient greeks alexander the great
the roman empire the vikings it was
those sort of ex
exciting quite you know quite masculine
manly stories that
that really inspired me to to sort of
take an interest and and i did from
from an early age um and of course it's
it's those sort of
things that you you read and then
develop i mean one of the first books
that my dad read to me
uh was was a children's version of the
odyssey and i thought you know one day
i'd love to go off on a ship and
explore the world you know i mean
hopefully not lose all my men in the
process but
uh you know but yeah i i definitely
thank
um those those those early years for my
what i'm doing now so the weird thing
about
one of the big differences about england
and america is the schooling system and
kind of the way you
test to get into certain levels and my
wife's a brit so i
i have some idea of it but you so you
went to
what what uh painsley is that right
painslee catholic school that's where
you went to
yeah so it was a non-fee paying it was
just an ordinary
state school um but it was you know as a
catholic school the you know catholic
schools um
were sometimes you know considered uh
better in
in some ways it had a real bent towards
science um that wasn't my bag at all but
um but good teachers and um it was one
of those schools that that you can
you can flourish in with with the right
attitude but but also you can get in a
lot of trouble
if you don't have the right attitude and
i i sort of did both
what sports were you playing um so i
wouldn't say i was hugely into sports i
i preferred i was into athletics so i
was a good runner as a kid
but i wasn't it wasn't really known for
its team sports and that kind of
frustrated me in in some ways because
you know i knew that i was kind of
sold on the idea of the army from
probably the age of about 11 or 12 in
fact so i knew that i should probably be
doing rugby
or something like that but it wasn't
really on offer in my school so
i had to be creative with with what i
was doing so i did a lot of personal
fitness
did a lot of running like i said um i
was interested in boxing from a young
age and that that's something i i took
up
and and that followed me into my army
career as well so what age did you start
boxing at
um i mean i was training from probably
15 16.
um when i went to university at 18 i was
in the university club
and then like i said did it throughout
the army as well so i know you
you went on like a this is
i don't know if americans do this or not
they go like traveling yeah
that's what you all call it right my
wife did it traveling right
and so and so you did that too like in
america you graduate high school then
you if you're you're going in the
military you're getting a job or you're
you're going there's no traveling
there's no traveling thing echo did you
go traveling
no sir no we're not going traveling for
a year but it's real normal
oh yeah it certainly is now you know
when i when i left school at the age of
18 in
2001 um
yeah i i knew that i wanted to join the
army and i was sort of
i really wanted to go to sandhurst and
go in as an officer and um
but because of my background i wasn't at
you know one of these posh private
schools
i hadn't you know necessarily got the
sports background so i knew i needed to
do something that would give me a bit of
an edge
and it was it was just go drinking in
australia exactly
but it was actually a stroke of a
fortune so when i was a kid i was i was
doing every odd job going i worked in
factories i was in shops i would
even flip burgers at mcdonald's just to
try and get some cash together i flip
burgers at wendy's there we go here we
go guaranteed
character building stuff making of great
military leadership flipping burgers get
some 100
um so i was doing all of that to try and
earn a bit of bit of cash before going
to university
and one of the jobs i was doing was
working at a theme park a place called
alton towers
and i think you know i was basically i
must have been on one of the rides
upside down and lost my wallet
fell out of my pocket and i was a bit
upset because i had my entire week's
earnings of about five pounds
[Music]
so i was quite surprised a couple of
days later when the wallet was returned
in the post
and not only was the the five pounds
still in there but there was also a note
from the person who had found the wallet
and it was actually signed off there was
there was a note saying
don't be such a you know i wouldn't say
the word if it's
an [ __ ] for um for losing your wallet
keep keep uh
better sort of care of your belongings
it was signed off by a certain
uh lieutenant dang um in the old in the
royal artillery
and i thought oh that's a nice nice guy
obviously not everyone who'd return a
wallet and um so i
you know i did the right thing and and
wrote a thank you letter back
i think my note would have said your
lesson is costing you five
pounds that's mine so i said
but because i was already interested in
a career in the army said have you got
any hints or tips on how to get into
sandhurst and by return of post came
back a six page essay
with all of these really great tips it
was like you know go and
learn how to you know read a map and use
a compass um
this is how many press-ups you need to
do to pass the fitness test all this
really
useful advice but the last sentence is
something i'll never forget but it said
above all travel dot dot dot because at
the end of the day you'll have some
great stories in the bar and the mess
so i took that to heart so i decided
based on that letter
which was all the serendipitous result
of me losing my wallet
that i was going to go away and do what
we call in england agapia
which is exactly what you say go drink
in australia so my
i told my dad and he said what on earth
is a gap year this wasn't particularly
popular
you know at that time and i said you
know i'm going to find myself on the
beaches of thailand
and he said well if you do that you can
go get yourself a bloody job
um so that's when i had to go and start
earning more cash and and
but eventually i did i went away
backpacking um and at the age of 18 you
know to literally just disappear often
the first place i went traveling was
actually in south africa
which is pretty pretty dodgy you know in
that time i went to zimbabwe
uh which at the age of 18 was the first
time i'd had a gun pulled on me
by a taxi driver who tried to rob me so
it was all really
quite um you know sort of it
teaches you a lot about independence so
what'd you learn about how to handle get
a gun pulled on you by the taxi driver
well you can't just throw that out there
and think we're just gonna let it ride
so so i bit it so you're in zimbabwe so
in zimbabwe i was traveling i've met
this random dutch dude who was much
older than me i was i was 18. this guy
must have been
29 30. and he was backpacking as well
and we were on the same
same route and um we got off uh the
train at a place called bulawayo
and um we we sort of got into a taxi and
asked the price to whatever the next bus
station
and he said it was going to be 40
dollars which zimbabwe has dollars
so 40 zim dollars was equivalent of
about two us dollars and we were like
yeah no problem so we put our bags in
the in the trunk of the car off we went
and it was like
two minutes around the corner we thought
okay we got out and he said okay 40
dollars
we got the zimbabwe dollars out and he
said no no no us dollars 40 us dollars
and we thought he was joking
and laughed at him he said no no put his
hand in his jacket pulls out a piston
and said 40 us dollars
and uh we're like oh [ __ ] okay well i
don't have four us dollars i'm on a
budget of about
two dollars a day right so we said okay
we'll pay but let us get our bags out
and it was quite a busy crowded sort of
car park
so um we got got our bags out of the
boot and then this guy this dutch guy
who's quite a you know quite a hefty
fella he said okay
come over here and uh the taxi driver he
put his pistol in
in in the car he got out so he was
unarmed at the time and this guy just
sort of
as he got his um as he got his bag on
his back just head-butted this taxi
driver
right and then looked at me and said
[ __ ] run so um
i ran and we escaped but this guy then
we jumped in another taxi and said
drive so but the original guy was then
chasing us through the streets of
of bologna so i had my first not only my
first sort of
gun pulled on me but my first car checks
at the age of 18 which was all pretty
wild
but it was those early travels that sort
of encouraged me to sort of yeah be
careful be independent-minded and and
start to think about
looking after myself what are the
chances that you made it back
through the first year of travels um
well well after that experience it was
all fairly tame i have to say but you
know getting getting drunk in australia
but it was no it was great and and it
was probably that first year of travel
really that
motivated me to want to do more because
you know apart from that
that one sort of moment it was it was
usual backpacking stuff but
throughout my time at university i went
to more and more
challenging and interesting places i
went to um
in my second year at university i was
studying history
and my particular interest was the
history of travel writing so i looked at
marco polo and his travels i was reading
about the hippie trail of the 1960s the
great pilgrimages
all the big overland journeys so i tried
to
make all my my my studies around that so
in the my summer leave i would try and
go to the places that i've been studying
around so
after one particular module bear in mind
this was in 2001 just after 9 11
it happened so there's a real focus on
the middle east and that was a place
that that i was fascinated by because of
its
the history but also what was going on
in in the news at the time
um so me and uh me and her buddy decided
one summer that we were going to go and
travel around the middle east this was
in
in 2003 so it was a second second year
at university
um the iraq war was happening and um
we said okay we're gonna go to egypt and
just have a look around and we went to
israel and then when we were in israel
there was
um a bomb went off in in jerusalem
caused the borders to shut so
what we'd plan to do was take a take a
boat from the
the coast from haifa to greece and then
go backpacking through europe
that was all now not on the cards um my
parents thought
thought me and my alex were actually on
holiday in greece at the time anyway so
they had no idea where we where we
actually were
the only board that was open was to the
east to jordan so we went to jordan
and then we were in jordan another bomb
went off which meant that we were stuck
in jordan the only border then
was open was actually further east which
was to iraq
so we took a taxi from the capital
jordan aman all the way to baghdad
at a cost of 20 this is i was 21 at the
time or 20
and i was met by a national guardsman on
the border who
said uh do you want to buy a gun he said
you're going to need it where you're
going
this is 2003. this is 2003. and um
we got to baghdad because it was the
only route that was open when in 2003
august
so the the wars it's on it's on yeah
combat operations are just
finished more or less but the you know
it's before the main insurgency had
begun but yeah
stuff was definitely exploding around us
at the time
and what part of this idea sounded smart
to you
well we didn't have another option we
couldn't afford to fly home from israel
because we had no money
and we thought it would just be a bit a
bit of an exciting adventure
and so we made it to baghdad but then we
stayed in the hotel
palestine which was the goodness in the
green zone
oh i know where that is that's freaking
crazy
we couldn't afford a night there because
it was 100 bucks which is a lot of money
when you're a student
and so we thought okay this was just
after somebody had just shot the top of
the hotel because they thought there was
an iraqi
insurgent it was actually a camera crew
um so we thought if we can sneak up the
the fire escape up the ladders then we
can just sleep amongst the rubble on the
roof
so we did that we got to the roof and
then there happened to be
a uk a british film crew filming a news
piece on the roof and they said
you know what are you idiots doing here
and we explained that we were sort of
backpacking through the middle east
and uh this guy's i would never forget
his name martin geisler who's an itn
correspondent said look
um you must be the first tourist in iraq
tell you what if we can do a news piece
about you
we'll pay for your room so we ended up
staying for a week because we couldn't
get we couldn't get out of iraq at this
point
and eventually we managed to escape by
hitching a ride with
some former sas mercenary security guys
who were doing the
doing the route up to crete which was
before saddam hussein had been captured
so we were actually
in to crete before saddam whilst he was
still down his little hole
so eventually long story short we we got
out to turkey and then eventually did
find it
find our way back to europe major amount
of survivor bias
on this whole thing so anyone that's
listening
you're you have to overcome this
survivor bias i'm gonna recommend
not particularly following this extreme
level of let's just go for it
what are you carrying in your backpack
uh as little as possible you know a
shmag just so we could kind of blend in
we had to go to the local market
to um to buy your sort of traditional
how many liters is your backpack
uh just just a day sack so you were
talking about 25 liters
you've got a 25 liter backpack yeah
that's it
that's it and we even put that you know
those sort of um plastic
big bags the sort of check check ones
that people go to the market
just so it didn't just so we didn't
stand out and we bought those
you know shiny shiny shirts and black
shoes that they they were in the middle
east so that we
i'm you know i'm quite sort of fairly
dark-skinned so we could blend in
and and it worked and we were just sort
of walking around the markets of baghdad
and
you know it was fine
do not try this at home do not try this
i didn't tell my parents still about six
months later
so then you finally so then you finally
get out how did you get back you just
hitched a ride with someone we
hit the rides contractors yeah right up
to the
turkish border and then hitched all the
way home to the uk
how hard is it to hitchhike these days
um
i actually i was i hitchhiked last week
actually in the states
and you got picked up pretty good yeah
it's fine um it depends where you are
but i've
you know i i used to love it because it
was a great way of
meeting interesting people and um in
fact when i
it's also
what my trips had taught me was you've
got to have a bit of faith in human
nature you know you have way more faith
in human nature than i do
i've done too many of these podcasts to
be jumping into
vehicles with random people it's weird
too because when i was a kid
and i don't know i guess i'm 10 years
older than you maybe
yeah something around 10 or 12. but when
i was a kid hitchhiking was very normal
yeah
you'd see it all the time people you
know you go get on the highway there's
people hitchhiking there's no big deal
if i miss the school bus we hitchhike
school things like that yeah but
nowadays people people are more scared
it's way more scared and
i guess that's part of that it's just
there's more news is more prevalent
like when someone gets kidnapped and
freaking raped and murdered
you you know about it whereas in 1978
it was just no factor no in your mind
that didn't happen to people
you trusted human nature yeah yeah
and all this is taking place while
you're going to college the university
of nottingham that's right
yeah so i was studying history every
summer we'd go off and do some
crazy adventure and um but it all kind
of built up really to when i graduated
in
the summer of 2004 um
so i was still desperate to join the
army but
i'd got the travel bug at this stage so
i wanted to sort of do something
even even bigger and better and because
i've been studying about these overland
journeys
i decided i should really do a bit do a
really big one
and um so i i thought why not actually
hitchhike
all the way to india following the
ancient silk road and following the
footsteps of sort of marco polo
so so i did i i hitchhiked from i put my
thumb up at nottingham service station
uh and five months later somehow made it
to uh to goa in india and and that was a
that was a wild journey because
it went through all of europe through
russia
um through the caucasus i was in
chechnya
uh i went through iran afghanistan and
pakistan over the you know over the
kaiba pass and then
and all of that you know i i was
fascinated by the stories of
you know victorian exploration the great
game particularly in central asia
afghanistan was was very much on my
radar then because
um you know the british army had just
sort of made deployments in kabul it
hadn't
things hadn't really kicked off in the
south yet at this stage but so it was
probably
fairly you know safe as it gets in
afghanistan to go traveling there um
but that was a journey i really really
wanted to do and so yeah off i went
and um again very similar thing i just
went with a small day sack
um i had no money i had i had total of
500 pounds
in my bank account that was all that was
left from my student loan and i thought
i'll see how far i can get
and it took five months so i was what
are you eating well
a lot 500 pounds feeds me for like a day
and a half
it does it does me now what the hell are
you eating
so not very much i was pretty skinny um
so yeah i was i was just
i kind of maybe i was a bit reckless but
i was just really putting my faith in
in human nature so on you know i
hitchhiked the whole way
um usually whoever i was hitchhiking
with you know
i was 21 right so people look at you
and when you tell them what you're doing
they think you're either mad or they
feel sorry for you and um
off the back of that i got invited into
people's homes you know i met a lot of
girls that way
and uh but but people would look after
you and often they would stuff
ten dollars into your pocket on the way
out or fill you fill your bag with with
with apples or whatever it might be so
i think i actually came back with more
than i started with okay so i'm starting
to think i'm starting to feel like
maybe things are different in life for
you and me
i'm just saying maybe you're a sweet
looking guy and i'm not
the last time somebody tried to slip me
ten dollars was never
you think i get invited into people's
homes that doesn't happen
so you're you're living a charmed life
i'm over here i feel like the world
might have been against me this whole
time
if i put my thumb out as you did
there's no one's going to pick me up
zero the percentage of people that pick
me up is zero
yeah it wouldn't happen these days for
me i don't think i think it's definitely
a thing when you're younger it's it's
far more likely
to happen i don't think i would how many
pairs of pants are you bringing with you
i went fully light scales
i had yeah one pair of one pair of pants
uh you know
a couple of shirts that's it really and
uh it was
it was great the freedom the liberal you
know the liberation of it all
it was it was it was brilliant i was
just sleeping at the side of the road i
had one poncho
uh sorry i had a bivvy bag ground pound
i didn't even have a ground pot now and
i was just you know if i if
if somebody didn't invite me into their
home i would i would just sleep on it i
mean in russia i remember sleeping in
the middle of this roundabout because
it was a busy city there was nowhere to
stay i couldn't speak a word of the
language so i just found this roundabout
in the centre of
some really grey industrial areas like
that'll do so and it was quite cold
so i had gone into this roundabout and i
saw some
uh what'd you call it todd pulling like
plastic sheeting that's perfect this is
going to keep me dry because it was
about to rain
going under this um tarpaulin and then i
heard some rustling i thought oh [ __ ]
there's some rats in there
and i sort of looked underneath there's
actually two other like homeless people
sleeping under this
this blanket so i had to move on from
there but um
yeah it was it was sort of experiences
like that that i you know i look back
and think what
was i doing but at the time it was it
felt like yeah
it was a it was a big grand adventure so
so
again what did you eat um whatever i can
get my hands on i was usually i was you
know one meal a day
i i tried to budget so i had you know
three dollars or whatever per day to
to spend on food but in iran i remember
i ran out of money
um in iran and um
the i mean literally i had i think i had
five dollars left and i knew i needed to
pay for a visa at the afghan border so
not only was i
had no money in iran but um i was going
into afghanistan completely penniless
i had like one traveller's check but you
can't train change
any sort of western travellers checks in
iran because there was a big
embargo on all that stuff so i remember
staying
i i went to this uh a small hotel in the
middle of the desert and explained to
this
the iranians are lovely people and they
they're very very hospitable and
everyone else
had looked after me but in this
particular place what about the russians
that let you sleep in the free place
what about them that restored my faith
in russians because i'm like the
russians didn't help you come on no they
did
honestly i was i was like i mean it was
it was tougher in russia than a lot of
places
um yeah it was it was definitely a you
know going
across the border into georgia was was
great because there was there was a
stark difference there
so you so you roll into to where in iran
i'm in a place called mashad which is a
big holy city on the near the afghan
border nowhere to stay
and i found this this one hotel it's
like a motel thing
and i explained to this guy i said look
can i have a room i've got five dollars
but i really need
three dollars to get the afghan stamp
because it was that's how much cost he
said look
you can stay for free on my office floor
and i said have you got any food he said
no there's no food but i noticed there
was a wedding
sort of party happening you said just go
and help yourself to the leftovers
so score you know there's always a way
there's always a way but
yeah i ended up in afghanistan um
literally no money
and but i knew i'd been told that the
afghans were pretty hospitable
and and they were i managed to sort of
hitchhike across the whole country
uh through herat i went through the
central uh mountains through chad charan
bamiyan
and ended up in kabul harry was finally
able to crash that traveler's check
how are you overcoming the language
barrier um by
hand signals hand signals i had a pretty
good beard at that stage so
the places that i was traveling to were
ethnically tagic and because i was i've
got a pretty good tan and a beard
everyone thought i was a pashtun so they
all
they all sort of kept the distance
because they thought it was a taliban
but as a result they were quite you know
they kind of looked after me and uh
yeah it was fine and then where did that
trip end
uh that ended in india so made it
through afghanistan all the way through
pakistan and then finally made it to the
beach in goa where i
sort of shaved the beard off and finally
had a beer and celebrated
still being alive
oh man once again i'm
i'm over here look i got four kids and
my opinion is don't try this at home
i'm glad you did it i'm glad you're
telling me about it i'm not encouraging
people to
necessarily do the same no actually
you wrote an entire book telling people
to do this stuff so i'm going to
disagree with you it comes with
it comes with a disclaimer all right um
speaking of the book i'm going to go
back to the book here for a second
because at some point um
well before i jump into that you you you
you get into sandhurst so what's the
deal with sandhurst sandhurst is not
like
west point where you go there and you go
to college for four years
no sandhurst is 12 months pretty much um
that's 44 weeks spread over a year you
it tends to be mainly graduates so
people who've finished
university but there is you know it is
open to people who
haven't necessarily been to university
and you spend 12 months there and then
you commission
into whichever regiment or core that you
that you choose to join and how hard is
it to get into sandhurst
tough yeah very tough um i started my
application process
i think i was 17 when i went into the
careers office with my dad
um you then do the um what was then
known as the regimental
sorry the um rcb um
basically the selection into san jose
you have to go to a place called
westbury
where you do all these sort of command
tasks lots of interviews
mental arithmetic all this sort of stuff
where you're tested for your aptitude
and your personality a lot of it's about
leadership it's showing not necessarily
having experience in leadership but the
potential to develop your leadership
is there any other ways to get your
commission
besides going like in america you can go
to west point or the naval academy or
whatever
or you can go to rotc which is you go to
college while you're taking classes
about whatever branch you're going into
or you can do offshore candidate school
so there's or you can be a prior
enlisted
guy and you can get commissioned how
does it work in england
so all officers have to go to sandhurst
even if you'd done
i was in otc whilst at university so i
did three years there is it a different
school for the army
versus the navy yes so there's three so
sandhurst is for the army
then you've got one um down in
portsmouth for for the navy
and then you've got crown wheel which is
for the royal air force
yeah but you're going to go if you're
going to get a commission that's what
you're doing
i want yeah exactly you've got to go to
sandhurst and so for me it was quite
daunt i'd heard about it
my dad had encouraged me he didn't get
into sandhurst
um he wanted to to join as a reservist
back in the back in the 70s didn't work
out for him so i felt like i was
my grandfather was you know he was an
enlisted private soldier so there was no
history of officership within my family
or although
i think there were five generations of
soldiers previously so we'd all served
in one way or another
um so to go to sanders was a real
privilege but also a big challenge
because there was
it was quite a daunting prospect you
know i was from a pretty normal
background and then suddenly i was in
the same platoon as prince harry
um so i was you know surrounded by a
totally different
type of people that i hadn't necessarily
met before um
lots of people who'd been big in sports
who'd gone to a very prestigious
universities
but i can say it's about leadership and
demonstrating the potential to be an
officer
now let's jump into the book um
i passed the army's commissioning board
which meant i could join as an officer
and command men something i found both
exciting and daunting
a young officer's training takes place
at the royal military academy sandhurst
and when i arrived there age 23 i still
wasn't sure
where i wanted to end up after visiting
as many
units as they want to see where they
might fit in
officer cadets can select two regiments
to have
interviews within their final term so
before you go to sandhurst you go and
meet with various units to see which
ones you like
yeah you do freaking cool is that you do
these sort of familiarization visits and
they can be as
formal or informal as the regiment
chooses so
you know a lot of the cavalry units
which are known to attract quite
uh posh well-to-do officers they just go
on a drinking binge for a weekend
other units you know the engineers or
the artillery do slightly more
um you know craft focused exercises
the paras i didn't i wasn't i didn't
look into the powers at this stage so i
i'd gone to visit my local unit the the
staffords i'd looked at the gurkhas
and i went to look at the intelligence
course so you go you basically go and
have a look around see if it's the right
fit for you
and and it's a two-way thing they might
not like you and say don't come back
so now you show up at sandhurst back to
the book sandhurst was hard work
and the late nights ironing my uniforms
the parades and long academic essay
academic essays were only part of it
there was a lot of running marching and
being shouted out along with field
exercises rifle ranges and blowing
things up as well as learning the more
subtle arts of
our officership fancy dinners the
intricacies of letter writing
and knowing the de brett's guide to
etiquette inside and out
it was an interesting and varied
education the de bretz
guide to etiquette yeah i i didn't even
know what this was until i went
i don't know what it is right now so
it's basically a manual of how to behave
like a proper gentleman yeah
give us one example well it's you know
it's i mean the basics of
you know if you're going to a
seven-course meal it's like which which
knife and fork do you start with first
yeah um it's how to write you know if
you're writing a letter to a
member of the royal family how do you
address them so
at when i went to officer candidate
school and this is only 13 weeks long so
you
but you do get etiquette training i
believe the only thing i remember this
is a weird thing to remember echo
charles take notes this could be
important because
it surprised me if you get a piece of
food in your mouth
that you didn't want in there the proper
way to get it out of your mouth
is to put it back on the fork and put it
down
so in other words if you if you're
eating a piece of chicken and there's a
bone in there
you don't pull it out with your with
your hand
you you put it back on the fork and you
put it down
now i think it's a lot more subtle to
you know put the hand up by the face
grab that thing you're like no i'm never
gonna know what i just did as opposed to
spitting the food back on the fork right
that's kind of yeah but hey that's the
tradition
they're the rules but that so in regards
to
that mm-hmm uh what if so it has to be
something like like a bone like hey
a piece of gristle you're eating a steak
and there's a piece of gristle that
ain't going down
yeah what are we gonna do put the fork
back next to your mouth this is a legend
look i'm not
i'm not even following this protocol
because i think that's a lot nastier
i'll clandestine move you won't know
what happened
but that gristle's coming into my hand
it's going to be somewhere on the ground
makes sense but what if and this might
go outside of the scope of even what
you're talking about what if
you eat some chicken that's like dry or
like well you know some new food like
escargot or something like this and
you're like oh first time
i don't like this at all do you spit the
whole escargot
on the fork or we have to go we'll have
to consult the depressed guys
that's a good direct guy i don't know
what to do i think you're in a tough
spot yeah
i had that happen i was i don't like
seafood and i was
with i was in sierra leone
and i was there was stuff going on down
there
and i was with my commanding officer and
there was
like i said there was things going on we
were trying to figure things out
so we get invited and i was like his
little sidekick guy was a
prior enlisted guy but i was had been
commissioned as an officer and he was
just
really taking care of me and showing me
the ropes and so he gets invited
to go see the charge affairs
which is the number two underneath the
ambassador in a country unless there's
no ambassador in which case they're
they're the the lead and in this
particular case there was no ambassador
so this
individual was the lead so we roll up
and this is in sierra leone there's a
freaking war going on there the echo mog
versus all that craziness
is happening in liberia it's just it's
just mayhem down in africa
so we roll up to this like really nice
house and every there's servants in the
whole nine yards and the first thing
they put in front of me is some kind of
crazy
like like no it's it's like octopus
shrimp and like raw fish all in one
thing
and i'm trying to do what i remembered
from you know adequate which is you eat
whatever you know they're putting
something in front of you they
they went the distance and so i'm i i
was just
i sucked it up bro i did it for the good
of the mission for the
day all right
a little detour there back to the book i
also took up boxing
everyone had to be part of a sports club
at sandhurst and i wasn't
into rugby or rowing boxing seemed like
a decent choice initially i hated the 4
30 a.m
starts but as fitness started to as the
fitness started to impact on me
and i felt myself improving i came to
relish the early morning alarm calls
plus there was the added carrot of the
annual fight night
in which the most dedicated committed
boxers were chosen to fight
watched by the whole academy as well as
a string of generals politicians and vip
guests i was incredibly proud to be
chosen as one of those fighters and on
9 november 2005 i stood in the ring
surrounded by
over a thousand people face to face with
officer candidate
mortimer i won the fight by knocking my
opponent to the ground
but i'm not retelling the story to
discuss the win i had a huge
i had a huge respect for my opponent and
the opportunity that came next arose
simply from having
stood in the arena after the fight all
the boxers were invited to the
sergeant's mess
a club of sorts where many of our
training instructors lived
this was a huge honor because it was
because this particular mess was usually
out of bounds and the sergeants
themselves
were only seen in their context in their
context as
authoritarian figures all muscles
tattoos
and shaved heads the fact that we
privileged few were allowed into their
private domain was viewed with
absolute envy by the other cadets the
sergeants crowded round the fighters and
congratulated us all on our performance
victors and defeated alike as i finished
my second pint of beer i found another
one thrust into my hand
looking up i saw it it was captain
truett the sandhurst representative
of the parachute regiment
congratulations wood
which regiment are you joining he uh he
said sternly
i hesitated momentarily before replying
i'm not sure sir
i was looking at the staffords or the
int corp
intel saw that he said you should join
the perez
my look of surprise must have been quite
apparent the peras
were the most fearsome soldiers in the
british army i'm not good enough to get
in the pair as i thought
you needed to be a muscle-bound machine
to get in surely it wasn't even on my
radar
sit down the captain barked i sat on one
of the little stools by the bar
beer still in hand first two rounds of
interviews have already been done he
told me
we had over 100 applicants and now we're
down to 20. i don't do this very often
and i won't ask you twice
but do you want to interview i sobered
up pretty quickly my entire future
rested
in the balance and all sorts of thoughts
crossed my mind what about the staffords
they seem like a nice enough bunch
and the intelligence corp they did some
interesting spy related work it could be
a good start to my career which would
allow me to travel too
when it came to the peras there were a
lot of unknowns as a regiment they are
shrouded in mystery
and are considered to be one of the
countries if not the world's most elite
military units
i didn't know what to expect and i
didn't think i was capable of joining
their ranks
the temptation was to play it safe and
stick with a more achievable goal
i knew what i was getting in to with the
staffords
if i agreed to an interview with the
paris i would automatically have to turn
down one of the other options since you
can only interview
with two regiments and the perez had the
toughest selection of all
just peaking the intelligence corps
if i turned down the staffords and
failed the board for the others i ran
the risk of not gaining any of my
choices
i could end up being a blanket stacker
in the logistics corps for the rest of
my career
the captain was staring at me
i'd like to interview sir i told him
expecting that it would take place in
the coming weeks
nope captain truitt launched into a
formal interview right there at the bar
grilling me about my own motivations
experiences
education and skills another 15 after
another 15 minutes he stood up
shook my hand and told me to report to
his office at 6am the next morning
and that's what i did hang over in all i
was fast tracked to the final eight
and then at the last interview with a
panel headed by some of the most senior
figures in the british army
i was offered a place in the parachute
regiment
that's how i got into the paras
freaking epic story
yeah i mean it's in hindsight it's those
little moments isn't it
that can change your entire the course
of your life and it was that drunken
moment
in a bar that you know
boxing is what got me in and that's
probably if i hadn't have joined the
paris there's no way i would have been
able to do
half the stuff i've done since then let
alone have the confidence to go and
spend uh you know 10 years exploring the
world so
i'm glad i took it up and i'm glad i
took the risk
and you made that decision in the split
you literally hadn't thought about the
pairs at all but i haven't even been on
my radar
and you thought maybe you weren't quite
capable of doing it
is that what kept it off your radar i
think
until that point you know i mentioned
there the staffordshire regiment which
was my local regiment and the
intelligence corps which
was was very difficult to get into more
from an intellectual capability
so i felt that in having the the ink
call that was gonna
you know that was quite a big risk the
staffords was slightly more guaranteed
in in many respects so
the paris you know like i say i you know
i'm not i'm not the sort of biggest
muscle-bound guy in the world and
and looking around at some of the other
guys that had been in the paris there's
quite a
there's quite an aggressive mentality to
get in there and like i said there was a
hundred
applicants for only six places in the
end
um so no it hadn't been on my radar but
i think the boxing which had encouraged
me to just have a bit more confidence
is what did it for me so and that and
and then the
the probably the drinks i'd had for the
in the bar at the time
if you just said no he handed you
another shot probably got you to say yes
do you keep in touch with this guy yeah
this guy freaking changed your life he
did yeah he actually
he sent me a message on linkedin the
other day which is quite a coincidence
because i've not heard from him for uh
for quite a number of years and i
mentioned that he was going to go in my
book and
he said why i said well actually so you
uh it was it was you that i can thank
for
all of all of what's happened and then
what about the guy that found your
wallet
nicest guy ever i've tried to track him
down i can't find him anywhere
one day i'll i'll send him a nice letter
back yeah it's just a good reminder to
people
to everybody you know you have the
opportunity to like completely change
people's lives
and and just by doing something cool and
nice and
it's freaking those those guys i mean
first of all
giving you your wallet back and your
money that's kind of crazy
um but then just giving you all a six
page essay on how to move forward and
and and you know what's look not
everyone's gonna take you up on your
advice
right cool and you give people advice
all the time and you might get sick of
doing it and you think well it's not
worth it but
you change one person's life and you're
a perfect example of that
of of your world changing because
these momentary decisions
and momentary mentorship from people
it's
unbelievable it's awesome um
let's get to the paras a little bit
going back to the book to join the
parachute regiment candidates must
undergo a tough selection process
called pre-parachute selection run by
pegasus company
which is usually referred to as pico pea
company yep
based at the infantry training center in
cataract
north yorkshire after 21 weeks of
training candidates are put through
eight tests to designed to test their
resilience and determination including a
20-mile
endurance march laden with a 16 kilogram
pack and a rifle in under 4 hours and 10
minutes an intimidating
assault course which is what you guys
call obstacle courses
and maybe we do call them assault
courses too let's go with the salt
sounds way cooler
17 meters above the ground
called the transient is that right yeah
and 60 seconds of milling
milling arguably the flagship event of
parachute selection
is a boxing match between candidates of
similar size and strength in which
determination and aggression are awarded
and dodging and blocking lose points
in short it amounts to being punched
hard in the head for a minute straight
while trying to hit the other guy
as much and as hard as possible if
either combatant sheds blood or is
knocked to the floor
the clock is paused blood wiped off and
the bout resumes
it is forbidden to aim at any part of
the opponent's body besides the head
and the winner is the most aggressive
candidate
milling is designed specifically to
replicate
quote the conditions of stress and
personal qualities required in a combat
situation
and test quote determination and raw
fighting spirit of the candidates it is
this raw spirit of controlled aggression
that sets peres apart from the rest of
the army
good times yeah i had to go to youtube
on that one and watch some milling
it's pretty cool it's freaking legit
just go as hard as you can it's pretty
sick unadulterated aggression
punching straight to the head you can't
back off you can't turn away if you turn
away
that's you you've you've screwed your
entire career it's all based on that
where moments especially as an officer
if you show any weakness if you if you
cower away
you you won't get in the regiment so you
could have spent months doing all the
other training you could have passed all
the interviews done the test i know guys
that spent six months
who were perfectly capable of doing
everything else and then they were just
a bit weak on the milling that was them
done
do they actually fail yeah and you're
not in and then you're not in then
you'll get sent somewhere else
did you have to like rearrange your
brain
from your boxing training to not you
know
parry and slip very different yeah yeah
because i would think your instinct
would be
you'd be slipping you know and moving
and head movement
and everything that you've learned to be
a good podcast you have to throw it out
the window and there's no training for
milling
the the only event that you do you don't
practice this at all
the first time most of the blokes
actually mill is is on their test
so you you know you're giving your
gloves and you're ex you're told the
rules and you just
go in it's a great spectator sport yeah
this is definitely
this should be a pay-per-view for sure
it's everything like
that the ufc wants right just punch each
other as much as you possibly freaking
can yeah how often do you guys get
knocked down a lot yeah like it's
every other one this guy's going down i
mean it's it's pretty full-on i mean
especially as the officers because
you're in with the the enlisted guys as
well
so there's probably let's say 90
enlisted guys and
like i say six officers and they always
with the officers i mentioned in there
that you'll usually
pull up against a person of your own
size and weight officers that's not true
they put you up against the biggest guys
out there
so i was up against this this huge guy
and it's all you take your tops off it's
all done sort of you know so you can
really
get the full the full experience and um
i was up against this huge guy
and i was absolutely terrified
probably because i'd already had my
boxing match you know at sandhurst and
which i'd won so i was quite proud of my
sort of undefeated
one win and then to go
milling where you're surrounded by not
only your
future brother officers but also you
know dozens of men that you will go on
to command they're all watching you
all their eyes are on you so you you
know you've got to put on a bit of a
an act a brave face of course but you
don't want to lose and
thankfully i did win and it was only
afterwards i mean i was i got a lucky
puncher to knock the guy out but it was
only
it was only afterwards that he came up
to me he had much taller than me much
bigger than me and he was like
good fight so he said i'll be honest i
was i was terrified i was like are you
serious like i'm literally half your
size
he said you were the sanders well no he
just said you're a parachute rodriguez
officer i was never going to win against
that
and i think that it's the its mindset
isn't its mentality and so he was
bizarrely it was nothing to do with
physical presence it was it was far more
against you know it's just that what's
going on in your mind and for him it was
to be up against an officer was
was um was a big thing damn they play
that game in the seals
you give the young e-dogs a shot at the
title against officer that officer
better
hang on because he's gonna bring it the
other cool thing is
i was watching the videos it's like uh
basically the ring is formed from the
crowd
yeah and it's small yeah what is it it's
probably it looks like you're not moving
you don't move your feet you're just
stacy that's taking a punch yeah
good times how much did you wear um
i was probably 80 75 killer 80 kilograms
yeah
yeah what are you challenging him
i'll leave now
going back to the book nothing worth
having comes easy
and we will need to work hard to achieve
things that we want most out of life
whether this is learning a new skill or
advancement in our professional careers
we need to be prepared to stay the
course and keep working toward our goals
no matter which obstacles appear along
the way when i was on my way into the
parachute regiment
i bust up to cataract for my
pre-parachute selection at that point i
had no idea
what the next 20 or so weeks would look
like for me all i knew was that they
would be the most stressful demanding
challenging
of my life so far but i had a goal in
mind i was determined to earn
that purple beret at the end the
recognition
of my achievement and my initiation into
one of the world's
elite fighting regiments that level of
drive is absolutely crucial
we can't give our all to anything if
we're not motivated
by the end result and if we're not
giving our all
we've no chance of sticking things
through when the going gets tough
over the first few weeks of selection it
was pretty clear that a lot of people
didn't have what it took
some couldn't handle the rigors of
training and fell behind others decided
that enough was enough
and dropped out of their own accord
midway through i had my own moment when
i thought my time
on selection was up i came down with a
shin
injury that sent me back behind the rest
of my cohort for a few days
unable to join in the rigorous drills
and knowing that when i was back in
action things would be exponentially
tougher for the time i'd missed
i'd wondered i wondered if this was
worth it
i started thinking about what my life
would be like if i failed selection
probably not all that bad i could
probably go and reapply
to one of the army's other more sedate
regiments then what have a fairly
average military career
perhaps go on some go to some
interesting places and do some
interesting things
but nothing grabbed me about it even
more so when i considered a life and
career outside the army having just
passed out of
sandhurst i couldn't for a moment
contemplate the prospect of a civilian
life
all i wanted was that maroon beret it
kept appearing in front of me every time
i closed my eyes
in a way it would have taken some
motivation to present myself to one
of the officers running selection and
tell them that i wanted to drop out
that i couldn't do it but i had no
desire to do anything besides recover
get back to training and persevere
through the rest of selection so that's
what i did
i pushed myself harder than i previously
thought possible quickly making up the
ground i lost
on the rest of the cadets i remember my
fear of heights being pushed to the
background
when i tackled the transanium my 60
seconds of milling passed in such a blur
i can't remember them all besides an
overwhelming need not to hurt the person
i was paired with but to prove to him
and everyone looking on
that i wasn't one for backing down
whatever the circumstances
perhaps i'm fortunate that i was born
with this amount of grit and
determination
it's not always a positive i've been
told many times that i'm as stubborn as
a mule
but up there in the cold wet windy
cataract
these inner reserves of dry vision grit
and resilience pulled me through
and i got the beret i've been dreaming
about
it's hard to think how different my life
would have been
without it
one of the reasons i i wanted to read
that little section was
there's a point where you're you're
doing a little bit of rationalization
like oh you know if i don't make it
you know like it will probably might not
be that bad you know and i have to put
up with this
and i i hear people rationalizing stuff
all day long as a matter of fact there's
a
tv show echo trolls it's called lost and
they basically take these people out
in the middle of nowhere and you're by
yourself i think it's called lost no
it's called a loan sorry it's called a
loan
and they go out and they put these
people and my little daughter
who's 10 at the time she got really into
it
and we would watch it and so you can
quit at any time you can key up your
radio and
sends out a transponder and they come
and get you but
you'd be listening to the people and
you'd hear them start to rationalize
you know and so i taught my daughter i
said you know what they're doing right
they should be like
oh he's rationalizing because you know
the guy says
you know you know i like being out here
and i love the nature but you know i
really miss my family and i realize that
my family's more and
i look at my little daughter and go
what's he doing right now rationalizing
he's about to quit
so i like the fact that you started
going a little bit down that path of
rationalization and
then you said you know what no it
doesn't work i think
you know we're all sort of prone to it
just to to varying degrees and
and when when when things get really
tough you know
those little elements of doubt
do have a tendency to creep in and you
just have to fight them you have to sort
of try and
look at your situation objectively and
realize what you're doing and that
rationalization thankfully is is
is uh is outrightly sort of castigated
in the parachute regiment and you're
reminded
stop rationalizing and the instructors
it might sound like they're shouting at
you but what they're doing is just
reminding you
not to give up so thankfully it's it's
stamped out pretty quickly but a lot of
it's on your own shoulders you know
nobody wants you to quit you know the
the
the unit needs officers that need
soldiers they don't want people to leave
they're not
telling you to quit they're telling you
to to not quit but so it's down to you
and people do this with every freaking
thing in everyday life all day long
like that last rep or that doughnut that
you're like you know i did work out hard
yesterday
i did work out hard and it's actually
it's really good to reward yourself
right it's good to reward yourself it's
good to have a positive feedback loop
when i did work out hard yesterday
and yeah i want to be i don't want to be
in a grind all the time you've got to
enjoy life yeah right
discipline because freedom how about the
freedom part here's the freedom part
you can rationalize anything you can
literally rationalize anything
if you're if you're not freaking careful
you will rationalize stuff that's not
good for you so you you get done with
this train is milling like the last
final thing
uh close to the end it's close to the
end i think but the most important
um event of all is something called the
log race and basically
there's a big telegraph poll i can't
remember how much it weighs but it's
bloody heavy
and there's like eight eight people on
each log and usually one or two officers
on each log
and it's a race so you've got four logs
or however many
how many days does it take no no it's
just it's one event
um on i think it's the second to last
day or
or the final day and it's basically you
are you're sent off it's it's about i
think it's three miles or something like
that
um and it's a race between the different
groups but you've got to stay on the log
if you come off the log as an officer
that will stay with you for the rest of
your career i know generals that
who you know in the 70s are still
reminded by their fellow officers that
they came off the log in 1975.
it happens so you you're made aware of
this so you you stand a couple of
officers did come off the log i stayed
on it um there was only two people left
on the lock and this thing is
bloody heavy there's only two people
left yeah and so you're pretty much
dragging this
this log up hills so when you say off
the log what do you mean like
you fall off and people people just fall
off and and they just pass out
i mean it's it's it's really heavy you
start with eight you've got to do two
you know like say two and a half or
three miles uh on an
off-road course it's up these you know
through through rivers and all this sort
of stuff and uh
usually by the end of it there's only
like top couple of people left
oh really yeah but the other people
still graduate uh they
do but if you fail two events on p
company out of the 20 or so events then
you're off the course
so when i was i was later an instructor
on p company
usually with the soldiers at least for
the recruits there's only about 10 or 11
pass rate so we'd start off with a
platoon of 90
or 100 recruits and we'd pass out 10 or
15.
so that's that's how tough it is damn
yeah and how long is the whole training
21 weeks
uh yeah yeah so if we're on a log
and we're going and i i've passed every
event but
i you know don't carry the log i
go to the side or whatever yeah i can
still be a para
only if you don't come off one of the
other events so if you fail
let's say the assault calls for the
trinasium which is the aerial assault
course where you've got to sort of jump
across
the high nets and things like that then
you'll be off the course so you can you
can get all the way to the end of the
the you know the course and if you come
off if you fail two of these events
that's you off then you'll get sent to
another regiment
is there a time limit on the log i
imagine if there's only two of you left
like
you take some time it takes it takes a
while yeah it's staying on is most
important and not just
giving up in the seal training you carry
a log you spend a lot of time with a log
but you also spend a lot of time with a
boat like these little boats
that used to be made out of rubberized
canvas so they were really heavy they're
a lot lighter now
than they were
but what's interesting so when i went
through you know you're carrying the
boat on your head a lot
and this is sort of what i thought you
were saying you carry the boat on your
head a lot
and you know if we're all in a boat crew
and there's eight of us in the boat crew
it's possible to sort of like shrink
your
head down a little bit and release your
posture a little bit and not have your
head carrying any weight which means
that everyone else is carrying the
weight
so when i went through it was like a
sort of um
like it was happening and you'd see
someone doing it and be like you'd hear
people yelling like in another boat get
your frickin head
under the boat man well they didn't have
this but they have it now they have
you can actually you get written up yeah
for what they call
duck boat so they'd be like charles your
duck and boat
and you can get like a demerit yeah they
didn't actually call it they didn't have
a name for it when i went through
but now they have a freaking name for it
because it's like a
it's like you're coming off your log bro
like you're not with the team
and that's not cool well we have the
same thing i mean because we have
there's a stretch array so the same sort
of thing where you're carrying a
stretcher for five miles that one
um so you can get through to the as
certainly as an officer it's more
apparent but if you can get through the
whole course even if you stayed on
all of the events you can get what's
called a stand-up fail
which is basically you're still standing
up but you've failed on your
attitude or personality so you can still
get booted off if they don't like you
yeah that's as it should be right
because there's some
there's some non-quantifiable leadership
qualities that some
people have or don't have and if if
someone you get someone that's looking
out for themselves and just
you know trying to step on everyone's
back to get to the top we don't want
that guy on the team
so you get done with that and
now you show up you show up at the
regiment more or less you've still got
to do
um the infantry battle school so there's
three months in brecken in wales where
you then go and do um no apologies that
was first p
company and then yeah that was to the
unit yeah
so i joined the unit in 2006
just as they my three power getting back
from afghanistan on the first tour
so it was a pretty that was a pretty
punchy tour as well and so you're just
missing
new me straight in charge of 30 more
veterans
and that was quite a daunting challenge
yeah what was your
what was your what lessons did you learn
from that um
well i'll never forget the day i was i
took over my platoon i met the guys
and you know you sort of taught at
sandhurst that you're going to have this
sort of
general montgomery moment where you're
sort of you know standing on a land
rover sort of addressing your soldiers
as they're all on parade
doesn't really work like that i sort of
walked into the barracks and they're all
in bed i was like
uh could i speak to the guys so they all
came together and
there was a corporal corporal crabtree
chris crabtree big guy
and i said sir can i tell you a joke he
said yeah go on
he said how many um sangin veterans does
it take to
change a light bulb i was like i don't
know he says of course you don't know
sir because you weren't [ __ ] there
thanks welcome aboard welcome aboard but
it was no
it was daunting but you know i felt
prepared you know sandhurst
the infantry battle school p company it
prepares you it gives you that
confidence you know
uh milling boxing all that stuff so
whilst it was like
quite something i'd already i'd
hitchhiked through afghanistan you know
a couple of
couple years before so i think when when
some of the guys started learning some
of my stories they had a
slightly more respect for me than they
probably could have had um
but it was still a big challenge you
know you've got to prove to your man
they're not gonna they don't they're not
just gonna follow you until they know
you're not
you know not a dick basically yeah how
long is it
your um what's the training like now
the guys come home i'm sure they stand
down for a little while and then let's
say we got to get ready to go back
so i think the turnaround was about 14
months before the next deployment so
there was a bit of down time there was
there was plenty of opportunity for the
guys to get some rest and
do things like adventure training um and
i mean there's there's a story in the
book
um where as a junior officer the
commanding officer said
this is the kayak go ahead
go ahead tell us so basically the ceo
said look all the all the new officers
so the six guys that we'd all just come
out straight out sanders you guys
pick a sport each and um and then get
all the guys to go and do something fun
so i said okay well i was looking at
sports and all my colleagues
i would have pretty much chosen what
their their their sort of
chosen sports were so somebody did
soccer football
um somebody else did you know ran the
rugby team
my only sport of course at that time was
boxing but three para already had a very
well established boxing team so there's
no way i could go and join that
so i was sort of scrambling around
thought okay well i'll just do kayaking
um it sounds like fun you know i i'd
done a bit when i was a kid
so i'll do that so i went to sort of
you know asked for volunteers i got six
or seven very unwilling volunteers from
the soldiers because they were they'd
rather be on leave but they'd all been
told they had to join one of these clubs
as well
now that's when things started getting
competitive because the powers being the
powers the commanding officer sort of
then threw into the ring he said look
you've all got to apply for whichever
sport it is apply for a competition
and you've got to win it because your
powers so you were just thinking put
together a kayak it was meant to be fun
and we'll go out in the river and we'll
have some fun and exactly
it'll be all good you can probably
travel yeah you're always trying to find
some scam to travel
exactly yeah but then he says hey i want
competition
so and i was based in a place called
colchester in essex
now there's no there's no sort of
particular venue to go and learn
kayaking
in colchester apart from the local canal
system now this was winter so
i basically managed to get hold of a
bunch of these boats and we were out
paddling
in the frozen you know dirty waters of
of essex canals now there's like
shopping trolleys floating around the
water
there was like you know the homeless
guys sort of taking a leak off the
bridge as we were going under it i mean
it was that kind of it was pretty grim
and so the guys were not particularly
inspired by this by this whole project
and and i was trying to find a suitable
competition to enter and that the main
kayaking competition in the uk is um
is basically a race it's a 100 mile race
along the thames
um from a place called henley to to
westminster it's called the divisors
to westminster race but that wasn't
until may which was
we were meant to be back in the training
cycle but then so the only other thing i
could think of or find
was over the easter weekend which was
the army uh canoe
polo championships which was in a
swimming pool a pool in a town called
aldershot which is the the home of the
paris
and so i applied for this um this
competition they were like yeah we don't
normally get powers applied but fine
turn up so
after we you know we've done like
several weeks training the guys were
just about competent in
staying in the boats without falling out
but no you know by all means
none of them could do a proper eskimo
role at this stage so we turned up on on
easter weekend
and the guys were all really annoyed
because it was easter weekend they
wanted to be at home with their families
and we found the the swimming pool
attendant the guy who's running the
competition he said oh you
didn't expect you to turn up and um we
got in our boats he said right get in
the pool
where's all the other teams there's
meant to be like six other teams
entering he said well it's easter
obviously nobody's bothered you're the
only people here
so we said well what does that mean he
said well you've got the gold medal
so out of all the teams that in the
paris to do all these sports we were the
only ones to actually win our
competition um
obviously we didn't need to tell anyone
that nobody else had turned up and we'd
won by default but it goes to show you
know if you
if you uh you've got to be in it to win
it so to speak
now you guys are going do you know that
you're preparing to go to afghanistan
yeah we knew
we knew that so in the deployment was in
the spring of 2008
um especially off the back of the first
tour that they'd been involved with the
powers were the first of the whole
british army
to to go into southern afghanistan into
hellmann and it was like i said it was a
um it was a very kinetic tour there was
a lot of stories coming out of it so
there was there's a lot of things to
live up to
so yeah so we deployed to to helmand
and um kandahar and um we were on
something called the regional command
group south so we were basically the
rapid response unit to go and
fly in in helicopters to wherever they
needed us
and it was a pretty varied role it was
it was interesting because we weren't in
one of the ford operating bases like two
para who were stuck in
in in one of these fobs for the whole
six months we were bouncing around all
over the place
um which meant that we would you know
one day we'd be doing a raid on a
taliban commander another day would be
helping the local police build a
police station another time we'd be
going out clearing the opium you know so
it was a really interesting varied role
but it did mean that we all had to get
our heads into this
you know 360 degree battle space hybrid
warfare
no two days were the same and so it was
it was quite a complicated environment
in which to
operate well who did you turn over with
did you get a turnover from somebody
when you showed up there
yeah we did um i think it was the royal
marines who were in there before us
um but the the role itself of rc south
was pretty undefined so
it was pretty much whatever the brigade
commander said we'd go and do so it
might be
the first job that we did was in a place
called maywand and we had to go and um
clear this this this town of any any
taliban
taliban elements i'd read about may 1
from my days doing history and
this was a place that the british army
had been in in 1842
and it turns out we were stationed in
the same fort as the british army
150 years previously so that was pretty
you know
interesting from from somebody who'd
studied the region
you go into some of your um some of the
operations in here
and some of the leadership really
lessons that you learned which are
great lessons i'm going to the book here
once
on operations in zabul province in
southern afghanistan my platoon was
given the mission to search a village
for a known terrorist recruiter
for the most part this involved being
invited by friendly women for tea
scanning their kitchens and gardens with
metal detectors and then being cursed
and told the house belonged to an
absent uncle as we dug up room and
removed
caches of weapon after walking around
all day we were low on water and needed
to get back to the helicopter pickup
point
which was five miles away across the
desert as we were leaving the village
i noticed a group of men huddled under
huddled around under the shade of a
mulberry tree
they looked shifty and stared at us as
we walked past
one of them wore a white turban and had
coal around his eyes looking like a
taliban leader
i got the translator to say hello and
ask their names which he duly noted
i reported the names by radio to our
intelligence cell
and they said they were all clear so we
left the men
and trekked back across the desert to
where my boss was waiting
by now the whole platoon was exhausted
and thirsty
we had not had time to eat all day and
the temperature
was over 50 degrees celsius which is
like 120 degrees fahrenheit
one of the soldiers was beginning to
wobble and and i expected it might be
heat exhaustion
then to make matters worse my boss came
over
lev you know that group of men in the
village yes
well the one in the white turbine the
incel now says
they want him in for questioning what
the hell i reported his name on the
radio and they said he was clear
i know they screwed up so what now well
we've got two hours before your
helicopter comes
go and get him i shook my head i had two
hours
and it was 10 miles a 16 kilometer round
trip
in the perez we have a well-known
physical stamina test
known as the 10 miler which is a
punishing speed march while carrying kit
they can be hard work at home in the
rain but out here in the desert low on
water i knew it might be deadly
i looked at my men and could tell that
half of them weren't up to it they were
exhausted but orders were orders
i figured that i could do the job with
10 or 12 men so half the men could stay
behind
i knew that in order to do so i had to
get them to buy into the vision and feel
ownership
so instead of barking out an order i
gathered my section commanders around
i told them the situation and asked them
what they thought were the best options
a lesson i learned early on is that even
if you already know the answer ask the
question it makes people feel valued
and part of the team and decision making
process it doesn't matter
who gets the credit for the decision and
when you
take your own ego out of the equation
it's amazing what happens
sir i have an idea said the youngest
corporal
why don't we leave half the men behind
and take some of their water
i'm sure we can do the job with 10 or 12
men men
that's a great idea i said patting him
on the back he grinned from ear to ear
and i made him the point man i need 12
volunteers to come with me i said
the rest of you can stay here the men
looked at each other they knew it would
be one of the hardest tabs of their life
and that it would be dangerous because
the taliban now knew our strength and
would have time to prepare an attack as
they saw us walking back across the
desert
private foster one of the new soldiers
put his hand up i'll come sir i need the
exercise he joked
sylvester was next then another and
another because we had a strong team
bonded with trust i had no shortage of
volunteers even some of the men who
i knew stood no chance of making it
started to put their hands up
because they felt ashamed but i already
had enough we redistributed the water
gridded our teeth and marched back
across the desert to the village where
we found the man in the white turban
arrested him
and marched all the way back again being
chased by an angry mob of afghans
it was a hard slog but one of the most
determined team efforts i'd seen in my
career
to top it off we later found out that
the man in the white turban was at the
top of the regional
most wanted list that victory and a
shared hardship
cemented the bonds of the platoon even
stronger there was nothing that my men
didn't think they could accomplish
legit i get it um often i'll get asked
you know how can i get my team to buy
into the plan and i always say let them
come up with a plan
simple isn't it let them come up with a
plan that's what you do
um and that's something you know you say
you learned it where
where do you think you picked that up
was it something that you saw the
instructors doing at
sandhurst is it what your sergeant the
way your sergeants ran thing
ran things i'll give you the honest
answer i was actually
i watched a series called shop i don't
know if you've ever seen it it was about
um i think so it's uh it was it was
basically
basically about the um the war um at the
peninsula war
in in the 19th century um but it's uh
yeah
chomping in it it was basically a
military drama series
and um it's often referred to in
military circles because it's
it's um it's a it was a fun war in the
sense that it was
it was in her what's the name of this
place called sharp yeah richard sharp
as in s-h-a-r-p p-e so in america we'd
say sharp
what you're saying here right now sounds
like shop but it's all good i'm married
to a brit i kind of understood it
so so sharp is a military officer he's a
commander in
the rifles and basically um often cited
as a sort of uh
figurehead in in leadership but i
remember watching that as a kid and
thinking ah he does exactly the same
when did the series come out oh it was
back in the 90s yes it's an old series
but i grew up watching shop so i think
that was probably where i first saw that
that style of leadership but again of
course it was drilled into us at
sandhurst and in training
to to you know bring your team into the
plan
yeah you know if you if you've got a
vision that's great but you've got to
get people to buy into it and i think
empowering people letting them take
ownership of those ideas is the best way
of doing that
yeah i totally totally agree
um yeah a lot of times even if you think
you have the answer and you ask the team
what they think they're going to come up
with a better answer than you had in the
first place
exactly so it's like why not just ask
them yeah
and i think ego is often the downfall of
a lot of leaders in in some ways because
it's when you
when you sort of uh when you think that
oh because i'm the leader i have to have
the answer
that's when things go wrong especially
in the military context yeah
100 100 that's a that's a killer
um leadership is the most important
thing on the battlefield
also pays to be lucky sometimes
another little section back to the book
one day we were setting
up a temporary encampment on the
outskirts of a lush valley i got the
call from my commanding officer that a
vehicle had been blown up a couple miles
away
and i was to take my platoon out on a
rescue mission our armored cars had
special tracks they could go over any
kind of terrain
we drove them across the desert and up
to the top of an escarpment
where the location of the explosion had
been reported
as we got closer i looked through the
front windscreen
and could see the remains of a land
rover blown to smithereens
i was expecting the worst as there
should have been
four soldiers inside i called the team
medic
and told them to get ready to treat any
surviving casualties
we stopped short by 50 meters in case
there were any other bombs nearby
and when i got out of my vehicle to my
absolute surprise and joy i saw that
all the men were fine when the land mine
had exploded
it had sent a shockwave through the car
sending everyone in it flying out onto
the ground they were all alive and
seemingly unharmed
i asked them if they were okay and apart
from being dizzy and shaken they nodded
and walked over to where i was standing
there was space in one of our three
vehicles so i put the men in the back of
the car at the front telling the lead
vehicle that we should reverse back out
of the danger area
because we might be in a minefield it
seemed like a sensible option
so that's what we did making sure that
we stayed exactly
in our own tracks until we were well
clear of the flat plateau
at that point my three vehicles needed
to turn around so that we didn't get
stuck
in a bottleneck between two large cliffs
so the front vehicle did a three-point
turn
and pushed around the other two so that
it was now facing forward
again in the lead we all did the same
and drove off down a track
back towards the encampment and by now i
was in vehicle number two
where the commander should always be
then just as we left
the scraggy boulder field there was an
enormous explosion
and i felt the shock waves hit my own
car after a second of deafness and
ringing in my ears
i looked through my windscreen to see a
massive cloud of dust
as it cleared i realized what had
happened the point vehicle had driven
over another mine
and to make matters worse it was the
same four soldiers
who had been in the first explosion i
shouted down the radio telling everyone
to stop
exactly where they were whilst i
considered the situation
i could see bodies lying in the dirt
next to the car which had the
front end ripped off of it now i knew i
had to show some real leadership
and there was only one thing for it the
metal detectors
were in the car at the back and it would
take them a good 10 minutes to clear the
path between the cars
let alone get to the front where we
might have heavy casualties
i got out of the car pulled out my
bayonet and began to crawl forward
stabbing the sand in front of me to
check for mines
luckily the car in front wasn't too far
and i was able to cover the distance
quickly
i reached the car and to my relief found
that yet again
by some miracle everyone was alive and
what's more uninjured
one of the soldiers stood up dusted
himself off and looked at me stabbing
around in the dirt what are you doing
sir he laughed you won't find any
taliban down there
it was a lucky day made even luckier as
i was filling out the daily report back
at camp when i found out that my team
and the remaining vehicle had been
tasked with denying
the half blown up cars that meant going
back to the site and blowing them up
properly with explosives so the taliban
couldn't make use of them in the future
it was a simple task and i was told that
i should remain behind
with the other platoon commanders so
that we could receive our orders for the
next day
as the team were driving back they too
hit
a landmine and the empty commander's
seat
where i normally would have been sitting
was completely destroyed by the
explosion
you can't be a leader unless you're
willing to put your team ahead of
yourself
when circumstances call for it this
requires moral courage and integrity
the building blocks not only of great
leadership
but of a fulfilled purposeful life
just out there digging for minds it was
a lucky day
a very lucky day and no one got in your
seat no one got in your vehicle
commander's seat
yep i was uh yeah i look back now and
thank my lucky stars that um
yeah that was a very lucky day what was
the op tempo
so like how often were you guys running
out going out on missions
well because of the nature of the job we
were like i said doing different things
so we'd we'd go out
and clear a valley one day we might be
out for a week then we'd come back to
kandahar we were based
in kandahar air base alongside the
canadians for the most part
um most of the brits were either in
bastion or in um
you know one of the fobs so it was quite
i mean kandahar
air base you know had a timmy horton's
coffee it had a pizza hut it had a
burger king i mean it was a bizarre
sort of experience so you're you're out
there getting blown at one minute and
then you're in
you're in with the with the ramps as we
we like to call them
another and it's such a bizarre thing to
get your head around
um but we weren't in there for long we'd
stay for a few days we'd regroup we'd
clean ourselves up and then we'd get
back out there
and we did some really fascinating you
know operations we did
according to um the news report at least
we did one of the biggest
airborne assaults of the entire of the
entire war we flew
um to into zabol with um
i don't know how many chinooks it was
like ten chinooks with apache support
to do a full battalion level assault and
um stuff like that when you've got
um when you've got ride of the valkyries
blaring out of the speakers
it it sort of it was pretty um you know
it was pretty energizing to say the
least
um equally you know we'd be out there
helping rebuild a school
painter paint a police station the next
so it was it was quite
it was it was challenging
on different levels it wasn't that we
were getting in as many fights because
actually the guys in the fobs
were getting attacked every day they
were immorted every day
um we'd often go for it for a week
without
firing a shot in anger so it wasn't
necessarily
the the the intensity of the fighting
certainly for my tour it was more of the
the variety and the scale of what we
were trying to achieve how long was the
deployment in total
normally there's six months i needed
four months because um
i was at the end of my tour as a platoon
commander so my replacement was sort of
brought in and then i i had to move on
to another job
so that's when i went to be a an
infantry uh
at the recruitment center i was then a
directing staff sort of recruiting
and uh training recruits back where i'd
done my
training before and for that's a
historical um
deployment for for the paras down there
i know i was i was doing just
some reading about it um you had a
corporal brian budd
who was posthumously awarded the
victoria cross sounds like he just
you know led a flanking maneuver against
enemy taliban fighters
ended up being killed but you know was
able to suppress enough fire that the
rest of his team could maneuver
there's another guy named um corporal
mark wright
award the uh the the george cross
um pretty i mean did you read the story
it's
like unbelievable story heartbreaking
story but
they're in a minefield there's guys
wounded
um he's as he's trying to get his guys
out of this minefield like
he's singing happy birthday to one of
his friends that's you know in a really
bad way and he
he ends up dying of wounds but i mean
just a just of
incredible um bravery and and
upholding that tradition of the paras
you know to this day
awesome stuff um
when you get back i i know you mentioned
in the book that you were
you were considering
um going a selection for for the special
special forces and then and then
well that was the net that was the
natural progression like i say after
after the tour
um it's it's considered the the next
step
is is mostly officers then go to back to
catrick to then train the next
uh bows of recruits i mean it wasn't my
first choice i didn't really want to go
and be in the wind and the rain training
recruits i would have loved to have
spent more time in afghanistan but um
but that's that's the way it goes you
know
in in the army so i was up in katric i
i'd say that
my morale was sort of flagging a little
bit because i i was actually
i wouldn't say i necessarily enjoyed
i've kind of stopped well i i
i did quite enjoy some of it um
but but that's why i joined the army and
so i was there i thought okay well
you know go for special forces selection
that will be the next thing so
um passed all the initial tests and it
was meant i was meant to be going on the
full selection in january
2009 and i was at my peak fitness i was
good to go and then i
made the the the error of um of going to
see my
girlfriend in mexico um who had a ranch
and um in a bout of uh silliness i i
decided to get on a horse and do some
rodeo on her ranch the horse threw me
over a six-foot wall and i broke my leg
uh a week before i was meant to be on
selection so
um i had to sort of limp in back to the
barracks and
obviously i was told i couldn't do
selection um needless to say
and what was worse was all of the jobs
for the next deployment which was going
to be happening in a few more months
had already been taken so
it was it was a crux point in my career
and i was like well
okay do i stay and then do a job that i
don't enjoy for for two years or do i
look at this as an opportunity and um it
was it was quite a pretty depressing
time because i
i you know i was desperate to get back
out there and do what i loved the most
but
but equally i didn't really fancy
spending two years doing a desk job
that wasn't why i joined the military at
all so i
i rang up my high school they don't tell
you about those desk jobs when you join
the military that's not even a thing
right
exactly there's no recruiting poster
that shows if officers sitting at a desk
making a powerpoint
exactly yeah excel is not what i signed
up for
so i after sort of really
you know going through from some
heart-wrenching decision-making
i thought you know what i think now is
the time to to do something else and
actually in hindsight it was because i
left hungary it was because i left
still hankering for a bit of adventure
and um
i didn't feel as though i'd done
everything i wanted to do in in on
that side of things that i probably it
gave me the impetus to to do what came
next so i i left and
by by sort of by twist of luck i suppose
when i because you have to usually give
12 months
notice when you leave the military but
when i rang up the um
army personnel somebody hadn't filled
out the paperwork properly
so um i meant that i could actually
leave in four months and my boss at the
time said look just take the time off
get yourself together
so i was on full pay and off i went so
as soon as my leg was fixed that was me
onto
whatever came next i didn't really have
a plan other than
linking to that other than thinking
actually now is probably the time i can
go back to that school schoolboy
dream of of somehow becoming an explorer
at what point did you climb merra peak
yeah so that was in that was again that
was just before i broke my leg it was in
october that yeah so
i was again a bit of down time
um i was given the opportunity to do
what you know as affection you know as
adventure training in the army which
usually involves doing some hill walking
in wales
i wanted to do something a bit more
exciting so i decided to organize a
proper mountaineering expedition to the
nepal himalayas um so i got together a
bunch of the
junior ncos um at catrick who were you
know my training staff and said
let's go and climb a mountain none of
them had climbed a mountain before
um but being paras they all sort of said
this sounds like fun
it's three weeks off work so off we go
and that was my introduction to
proper um civilian style
leadership in many ways because it was
you know we were not in uniform we were
doing
learning a new skill um in a new
environment so
um off we went and we went to climb mira
peak which is
not a technical mountain but it's six
and a half thousand meters which is
what's that that's like i think it's
about twenty one thousand for 247
um so it's it's a pretty high mountain
and the airs they're not there and you
know you can suffer from altitude
sickness so often it's a three-week
expedition
um and it was it was actually pretty
demanding especially for some of the
guys who'd never been to that altitude
before and i'd been backpacking in nepal
and i'd done that sort of thing but i'd
never
never ever been to that sort of height
so it was
it was a really interesting lesson in
motivating soldiers who soldiers love to
complain at
the best of times um especially when
this is their
vacation time so um it was all fun and
games until we got to sort of 5 000
meters 15 000 feet and that's when
things get really tough
and cold yeah you you break it down
really well
um i'll go to the book here after more
than 10 days of hard trekking we finally
reached the snow line where the
temperatures plummeted to minus 27
degrees
and with gale force winds making the
setup of camp a dreadful prospect at
least three of the others
and i were suffering severe headaches
dehydration and very cold feet as we
tried
unsuccessfully to sleep at 5 000 meters
on the summit day we
agree we were greeted with clear
conditions but two of the local sherpas
decided to remain with the tents
in camp rather than ascend to the top i
led the way with
jordi yeah i led the way with jordy and
our mountain guide jason we plotted
through the thick
snow tied together in case a crevasse
opened up
it was punishing slow going and every
step was hard earned with short gasping
breaths
the summit came into view a few hundred
meters ahead
but there was no time to celebrate as we
stopped for a short break
one of the soldiers approached me
complaining that he couldn't feel his
feet anymore
his boots had been on the tight side and
as a result his toes were right up
against the edge of the boot
as we'd been trained i ordered him to
remove his boots and socks and
i placed his bare toe inside my jacket
right up in my armpit
where it would be able to warm up to
body temperature naturally
as we waited i saw another soldier
shifting about
he told me his feet too were numb and so
after a while i offered the same service
to him but before long my feet were also
getting so cold
they were excruciating we needed to move
so once we'd taken a rest we pushed on
another 100 meters to a crack
by then just before the final push to
the summit disaster struck
a howling wind flared up the valley
followed immediately by a white blanket
of cloud
i knew instantly that even if it was
short-lived they would add time on to
our exposure
which might mean the difference between
someone keeping or losing
their toes to frostbite we had trekked
for days
and planned for months no one wanted to
give up
boss one of the soldiers shouted shouted
we can make it it's not far to go
200 meters more i looked up into the
murky abyss of frozen air and then back
at the faces of the two shivering
soldiers
i was torn from the looks around me it
was clear the overwhelming urge of the
group was to continue
these were all paratroopers men proud of
their own heartiness and expecting it
above
all from me their leader but i knew that
if
i decided to continue i was putting all
our safety in danger
and the fault would be mine alone for
any consequences
we turn back i shouted now i hauled the
youngest of the crew to his feet and
pointed down the slope
back to where the camp back to the camp
where the shirt was waited for us
the most headstrong of the soldiers
muttered and shook his head i didn't say
anything or blame him i was just
as disappointed as he was we all knew
that our chance of conquering the
mountain was gone
at least for this expedition months of
anticipation and weeks of physical
training had gone to waste
as we got back to the tents and packed
up the camp we were all silent
it wasn't until hours later when we
descended beyond the snow line
and to a sheltered gully where the sun
had warmed up the rocks
that one of the senior soldiers
approached me you made the right call
there boss
otherwise we might have died or at the
very least we'd
be we'd all be missing a few toes as we
carried
on down the trail the disappointment
that we felt at not achieving our aim
seemed to dissipate and we were glad to
have come down unscathed
having lived to fight another day i had
not wanted to make the decision to turn
back
it felt like failure and i was worried
about the impact it would have on my
soldiers estimation of me
but as i discovered afterwards even
those
who had wanted to continue at the time
had a lot of respect for the decision in
hindsight
moreover that defeat instilled a
wonderful attitude in those eight
soldiers after the expected banter and
complaining that all sages
soldiers are good at every single one of
them said that the trip was one of the
highlights of their military career
what's more many of them later became
serious climbers and mountaineers
and went back to summit mirror peak
if i had made the popular decision that
day
rather than the right one it could have
been a very
different story
just another and look i i usually say
this in the beginning of these things
i'm obviously reading only like tiny
sections of the book
you got to get the book there's all
kinds of lessons learned throughout this
book about leadership about
discovery about exploration just it's
full of them
so get the book um but that's that's a
good highlight a good
lesson learned and this is now and so
that's sort of your intro
to well maybe i can do maybe i can do
something like this in the civilian
world yeah
it was and so when i left when i managed
to get out of the um
out of the army like i said broke my leg
i was disappointed at not
being able to do special forces
selection but i was still hungry and
that was that was the key ingredient
because i was desperate to do something
that i felt was was worthwhile um
most most of my fellow officers who were
who left
the military um at the sort of rank of
captain or junior major
they were sort of at the process of
getting married settling down
and wanting something slightly more
stable you were just understandable and
i was just getting warmed up
so a lot of them went to work in london
in finance or uh consultancy
something with a bit of cash at that
stage i wasn't motivated by buy cash at
all i just wanted to go and have
adventures and approve things you said
we're gonna go have
adventures some of it was fun
so i thought there's got to be there's
got to be something in this and so while
i was kind of
planning i wanted to bring together my
passions of writing of
i sort of had an amateur interest in
photography and of course travel was
kind of at the heart of everything that
i did so i was planning
and i was chatting to a friend of mine
tom bobkin who was um
at that stage also in the process of of
leaving the military and we we came with
this idea
um of setting up some sort of a travel
company taking people on adventures
expeditions
he saw a few months left to to before he
left the military so in the meantime
i volunteered for a for a charity a
friend of mine had set up a charity
in africa in malawi and what they really
needed more than anything else was
vehicles they needed a couple of
ambulances
and so she was like is there any way you
can you know somehow while you're
sitting around
plotting your next trip why don't you
send me some ambulances raise some money
or something like that so i said okay
but we're gonna do this the fun way so i
i basically got together a bunch of my
friends
um told them to take two months leave
whatever they were doing
and we were going to buy the ambulances
on ebay and drive them to malawi
10 000 miles away and that's what we did
i managed to raise
probably at 50 grand not a massive
amount of money but bought a couple of
20-year-old land cruisers off the
internet painted them white taught
myself basic mechanics
stuck a flashing light on the top and
off we went and we drove all the way
through europe through the middle east
went through syria
you know all these crazy places and two
months later
went to you know finally delivered these
ambulances to
to this little clinic in in malawi and
it was such a rewarding experience i
mean it was a heck of a road trip
but it was it you know it's for a good
cause and these ambulances are still
being used today to save lives and
and there was something about that that
really i found really rewarding
and i thought well maybe if there's a
way of commercializing this i can turn
this into a lifestyle and and that's
what i did so when tom finally did leave
the army
we ended up setting up a company called
secret compass which basically
offered military-style expeditions in
some of the most remote
places in the world to civilian clients
but with a very military ethos we're
going from a to b
it's going to be tough everyone needs to
get stuck in everyone needs to
wash their own dishes this is not a
package tour let's go
so the first trip the flagship trip we
did was horse riding in northern
afghanistan
which um in 2011 i think that was
up in a place called the wakan corridor
which is completely unaffected by war
and the taliban
um but it was you know it sold out i
couldn't believe it so
how many people it was only about 12 or
so people so
small group trips the next one we did
was um mountain climbing on the iraq
iran border up in kurdistan
and that was pretty special too we then
went across the sahara desert in sudan
with camels
we we rafted down the nile in south
sudan walked across madagascar
all these sorts of insane trips but it
was so popular
it wasn't long before we started getting
the likes of discovery channel and
national geographic calling us up saying
look
we've seen these kind of trips you can
do can you take our journalists and our
film crews so
that was a bit of a segue into the world
of media and before we knew it we were
taking these highly respected film crews
and journalists and directors into syria
iraq wherever you wanted to go
and um we met all sorts of people i mean
i ended up doing the sort of security
for george clooney at one point it was
it was wild but
um that was how it sort of led on to is
he an actor or something or a
politician george clooney yeah yeah i
want to know he's a bit of both isn't he
at some point i think it was 2010 you
you started writing your first book
yes and um
you you write about it in this book you
write about writing your first book and
one of the one of the things you say
you're like talking about the challenge
of writing a book
and the quote that i that i liked was
you said are you really going to feel
more inspired tomorrow
or do you just need to be firm with
yourself and get started once again it's
rationalization well i really don't feel
like writing to today maybe i can wait
until tomorrow
you so you started writing this book and
you go through your methods you know
with some
you know about how you lay it out and
you're you're very
methodical about your writing um
how'd that book you know what the
publishers just jumped all over that one
huh
sadly not so this was when i was trying
to set up a business i was trying to
have fun i was trying to get over the
fact that i'd
left the army and wasn't i hadn't quite
achieved what i wanted to do so i
thought okay what i'm going to do is
going to write about that trip that we
discussed before
when i hitchhiked to india because i
thought it was interesting um
whether or not anyone else did was
another matter i i wrote this book
hundred thousand words
um pitched it to agents publishers
and basically got told to piss off at
every every turn nobody was interested
they said you know
nobody cares about your holidays so um
it was quite disappointing but i'd
written a hundred thousand words it was
on my laptop and
i thought okay maybe this book's not
good enough but
it's been a really useful learning curve
it's it's given me an introduction to
writing and the process
and that inspired me to to carry on and
but i knew i needed to do something that
was more impressive something that would
get picked up
and and that's how it led on to the sort
of
the bigger expeditions later on so you
were thinking i've got to do cooler
stuff
if i'm going to write a book about it
and people are actually going to be
interested exactly
yeah what was the first step towards
that what was the trip that you said all
right this is this is worth writing
about
so like i said i was looking at freaking
horse riding in afghanistan
well no they none of those were big or
bold enough they were all cool trips but
they were two they were still two week
you know trips oh you said two weeks two
weeks yeah these were all like
short trips that the paying clients
could come on and whilst it was fun
guiding trips for paying clients it
wasn't the kind of stuff that i could
write about but
it was it was all it was all leading in
the in the directions
were you guys profitable uh quite the
opposite so
i was i was i was homeless i spent three
years
bro you've been homeless since you were
like 14. no but this this was proper
homeless i was i had
uh i basically whatever money i'd saved
up from the army i'd invested into this
company with my buddy
which meant i didn't have any money for
rent so i was basically staying
on friends floors um for three years but
i also had a rule that i'd learnt
in india i'd stayed at a gurdwara at the
uh
the the golden temple in india and it's
part of the sikh
religion to offer hospitality but only
for three days and three nights
after that you can move on so i'd
adopted this this
i i quite like that because you don't
want to like you know sort of burn your
bridges or
or outstay your welcome so i'd adopted
this mentality and i was pretty rigid
with it so for three years i never spent
more than three nights in one place
so i'd stay with friends and even if
they insisted i stay longer i said no
i'm gonna i'm gonna move on so i kind of
did this big rotation throughout
all my friends in london but it did mean
that there was a few occasions where
there was gaps and i
i slept on benches i'll be honest i
slept outside and whatever it took and
it was it was a pretty tough experience
because i you know i was kind of living
on one or two meals a day maximum
because that's all i could afford
especially in london it's not cheap and
then you know i was surviving by going
away on these short expeditions where at
least my expenses were paid for you're
stoked to go to afghanistan
so you can get a meal just so i could
get fed yeah for sure and then but
whenever i was back in london for like a
week or two weeks i was i was poor i had
no money what was the up tempo of
these trips how often were you going on
those a lot you know it would be i'd be
away for two or three weeks then back
for a couple of weeks then away from you
so it was basically
nine or ten months of the year i was
away why wasn't the company profitable i
mean
i would imagine your clientele must have
been people with a lot of money
and for them the difference between how
much would it cost if you wanted if i
wanted to go horseback riding in
afghanistan what were you gonna charge
me well it's probably about
two or three thousand pounds so five
thousand dollars okay so not
super money i mean we were aiming at
that high-end clientele
but at that stage we just didn't have
the contacts we didn't know those
circles of people so we were trying
aimer at the more mid-range budgets
people who were adventurous who had a
bit of cash
but not we're not talking billionaires
here we're talking
you know people that work in the city i
mean we had all sorts of people teachers
i mean people who just saved up all year
to do that one particular trip
what about your buddy todd tom tom what
about him where's he living
well he was married so he he sort of you
know he'd already sort of
managed to get himself sorted uh so he
had a he had someone to live unlike me
um so we were in slightly different
places but um
but but for me it was like you know i
was using all of these trips as an
opportunity to to learn the craft of
writing to do more photography so i'd go
away and do this horse riding in
afghanistan
take some photographs and i'd try and
sell them to you know lonely planet
guidebooks or the newspapers whatever it
might be so i was trying to build a
position will you get any bites on that
yeah i was it took a while i mean i was
doing my fair share of weddings and baby
photos but
it was all building up and um but it was
on one of these trips i was out in south
sudan
doing it making a film out there um
it was a fishing fishing show about a
guy that was um
fishing for nile perch in the middle of
a war zone and the only problem was he
he was didn't really catch any fish
which doesn't make for a particularly
good fishing show
um and and when we were back in juba
which i don't know if you've been to
juba but it's it's
it's there's nothing there i mean it's
the world's newest country at the time
south sudan
um it had about three miles of paved
road in the entire country i mean
even in the city centre it was just like
dirt huts so
pretty rudimentary place we were out
there trying to make a show about
fishing but hadn't not caught any fish
the whole thing was a bit of a disaster
turns out that george clooney was in
town doing some of his humanitarian work
and um he he'd landed we tried to get
him on the show we thought at least if
we got george clooney in the film
it's gonna sell just for the sake that
he's in it um
the only problem is that the cameraman
who who was supposed to be filming
george clooney because he was so
starstruck
turns out halfway through the interview
forgotten to press record so that was a
disaster as well
but we were out there we were kind of as
a reputation with it within the film
crew
um we thought this this whole thing's a
complete mess there's shambles and we're
going to go back to
channel 4 who commissioned this thing
with our reputation in
tatters at this point so they
commissioned your company to film this
it wasn't my company i was just a
freelance health and safety guy
i was part of secret compass but we you
know we basically saw
something you got contracted out yeah so
so channel four is paying
someone else to make this show to make
the show and you're just a helper i was
a helper doing all the behind the scenes
logistics safety
keeping people fed and watching and you
recognize that this isn't going well
this guy hasn't gotten a freaking fish
yet he hasn't got a fish
george we've only got show up yeah
exactly
i ended up having to be george clooney's
hand double because they screwed up the
first start of the interview i mean it
was like
it was pretty bad but that's how i met a
guy called neil he was the
the second um he was the producer
director on the show
a second cameraman and he said look lev
you know
we could do this ourselves why don't you
get why don't we film one of your
expeditions
you know cut the crap let's go and do
something cool he said have you got any
ideas and we were in south sudan on the
banks of the night and i sort of looked
left and right so i was whopping great
big river and i said well
i wonder if anyone's ever walked the
length of the river nile and he said
well i'd highly doubt it because it's
four and a half thousand miles long and
i'm full of war zones
so i said well let's do it and so that's
where the idea was born
um i decided i wanted to be the first
person to walk the entire length of the
river nile
and i thought that's that's big enough
and bold enough to write a book about
and get published
so that was the plan and that was the
plan that was back in 2012
and it took me about almost two years
certainly 18 months of planning
fundraising trying to get tv interest
trying to get a publisher all that sort
of stuff
but i was determined that come on may
without even even if we don't get the
support of tv or or a book i'm gonna go
and do this and
just by committing mentally
i think that's what did it it was the
confidence of then just walking into
these meetings saying
screw you even if you don't give me any
money i'm doing it and i think people
saw that
and then the sort of the i guess the
credibility of having been a paratrooper
that that got people bought into this
vision and and somehow i managed to get
the tv commission uh but publishing deal
and everything else and got the whole
thing fully funded and so off i went
took nine months walk for four and a
half thousand miles
from rwanda through tanzania um
through uganda south sudan all the way
to the mediterranean in
egypt and that was a that was a rough
one i mean i
i know um in reading through this you
had one of the guys that was with you a
guy
matt matthew power yeah matthew he was a
journalist and
yeah he he yeah he he came out to write
about me for uh for a magazine
um and and sadly passed away from heat
stroke on the way and that that was a
real
kick at the ass because you know it
brought it home that this was real this
wasn't just some
some trip away um you know stuff stuff
can go wrong and sadly does go wrong
sometimes but but it really brought it
home and
it made me really question the validity
of this you know what
was what i was doing right you know um
but you know it happened and i thought
i've got to carry on
i've got to finish this um for his
legacy
as much as anything else to to make if
if i give up now
then what was the whole point in any of
it so
so this was so a tv crew is with you and
they're filming
not the whole time no i mean the journey
at the time when i set off i didn't know
how long this would take i'd anticipated
about a year
and you know you can't afford to pay a
crew for 12 months to follow me around
so they came out
four or five times for anywhere between
three or four days and a week
so they were only on the ground probably
a total of about a month
out of the nine months that i was i was
on my own
all with local guides you know i always
try and have a local person with me
as an accompaniment but places like
sudan they couldn't even get in because
they weren't issuing journalist visas so
i was on my own for like two months in
sudan
how many miles were you doing a day um
so i started
doing probably you know 10 miles a day
in in places like rwanda where it's
quite hilly um but when i was
really into my stride in in the desert
in sudan i mean it was hot it was sort
of august september time
with with 120 degrees in the desert but
probably averaging 45 to 50
kilometers so 30 miles a day
and then this tv show this is a tv show
that eventually
a four-part series walking the nile
which then aired in the uk
and in in the states and globally and it
was a huge success
far more than i'd ever anticipated um
book became a best seller
and yeah it changed my life you know i
suddenly wasn't homeless anymore
when uh is it like on netflix where do
you watch it uh it was on
discovery channel in the us it was on
channel 4 in the uk but you know you can
still find it find it online yeah
it's still out there did you feel like
these bastards that filmed it only came
on this thing for like three weeks and i
was out there for nine months
well we all became friends and actually
to this day like neil who's
the the guy who originally inspired me
to do this for tv um
we're still you know best buddies and we
still you know i've now set up my own
production company so i make shows for
other people and for myself as well and
he's on the team so
um so yeah we all became very close i
mean you tend to when you're in those
sorts of circumstances i mean we
were in south sudan in the middle of a
war zone you know it was uh
i mean they weren't there at this time
it was just it was just me but
um i was gonna say because you become
close and then they're like hey i'm out
going back to england for two months
all the exciting things happened where
they weren't there i mean we were in a
place called boar this was
during the um just the uh the sort of uh
there's a big
big civil war happening in south sudan
it was um they just got a new country
but there's still a lot of tribal
fighting
i turned up in this town called boar uh
the same morning that 60
members of a tribe had been murdered
inside uh inside the united nations
refugee camp um the whole thing was
kicking off i found myself on top of a
you know this bombed out hotel with the
rebels approaching on one side
you know tracer fire going over heads
there was mortars landing nearby and the
only alternative
apart from watching the fireworks
display was climbing down the the ladder
into the river now which was filled with
crocodiles
so it was it was a pretty hairy time and
lots of things
you know like i said can do go wrong but
turns out that makes for good tv
then you so you get done with that you
you got a place to live now
you're kind of going in a different
direction as far as financially
uh but now you got to start plotting on
things like are you thinking yourself
all right
i gotta one-up myself well it came
pretty quickly you know
the the show was successful um i was
then asked
you know literally a couple of months
later where's next and of course people
want bigger and better
i thought when i've just walked the
entire length of the river nile i mean
what's bigger and better than that
so i thought well what i'm going to do
is i don't want to be a
one-hit wonder or a sort of flash in the
pan i need to think
the long game so i i sort of
squared it away in my own mind the kind
of journeys that i wanted to do the kind
of places that i wanted to visit and i
wrote down sort of my values the the
things that i will not move
away from and it was actually going back
to my
degree doing my degree at university i
said i'm gonna i'm gonna visit places
that
hold a genuine interest um because at
this stage i was getting all sorts of
offers to go and build you know sort of
log cabins in in the woods in alaska and
do fishing shows and do cooking shows
all of which are great and interesting
but if i was to
actually see this as a long-term career
i need to sort of call my own niche and
so
i thought by doing journeys either on
foot or certainly at the slowest pace
into places that have got a bit of a bad
reputation there's a there's an
interesting way of shining a spotlight
on places that
really need it so i thought why not pick
a geographical feature i
the himalayas seem the next obvious
choice the biggest mountain range in the
world mount everest
and walk the length of that so i thought
i'm going to start
at the place that placed very close to
my heart afghanistan in the pamia
mountains and walk
all the way to the tibetan plateau and
that was another journey of
two and a half 3 000 miles and that took
about six months as well
so that was the next big journey which
happened 12 months later and then ever
since then i've been doing one big
journey
pretty much every year since then are
you going so were you solo when you
walked the nile
uh well i said i always have a a local
guide they would they would change over
depending on which country i was in so i
was anyone to do the entire what about
the himalayas
solo uh and the crew would fly out and
meet me
along the way to film what they thought
were the bankers and then
but you know it's always the way that
the most interesting stuff happens when
you're
either on your own or or in a very small
crew because the moment you've got a car
with a
with a crew there things are not quite
the same people sort of close a bit and
they're not as open so
a lot of the interesting stuff happens
um you know when when you're
unaccompanied um which is
what happened when i was in nepal and my
car was i was the one time
is the the irony of a walking expedition
is the one time
um that i decided to get a taxi because
i was told i couldn't camp in
in this particular village and i had to
move on to the next um that was when i
had a pretty big accident
yeah tacos that you write about in the
book talk us through that one
so it was um i'll never forget it it was
the 19th of august 2015.
um i was i was in a town called mussy
cot
with my local guide bin odd and actually
my brother who'd flown out to meet me
a day before to join me for a week of
what was his annual holiday
um i know the story so i can just
imagine your brother yeah cool you're
going to vacation
yeah so so we're in the mountains
and it was just it was almost nighttime
uh it's getting dark
and most of the time you know i'd
already been walking for three months
here
um we'd just camp in the villages or
stay in locals houses whatever it
whatever it took
but there was a maoist interaction in
this part of nepal so the communists
were were taken over villages and they
didn't take
kindly to to foreigners because you know
they just said
and they weren't aggressive they just
said look you can't stay here
go to the town and then you can come
back tomorrow and carry on your walk but
you're not you can't stay in this
village because we're having an internal
dispute so we said fine so we got a
local taxi got in it
drove over the mountain pass and just as
we were going over the
crest of the cliff the brakes failed
so the car goes careering down this this
this this
road and unable to slow down
hits the side of the wall and bounces
straight off this this cliff top
and um when i say cliff top it was uh it
was a huge fall
straight into the forest below um about
150 meters
which is what's that 450 feet to the
bottom of the gorge
and somehow you know again thank you my
lucky stars did you ever see belton
uh there were no seat belts in this car
i mean it's uh it's i guess the airbags
weren't popular
what kind of car was it it was a
mahindra jeep so it was a metal frame
thankfully not some
not some cheap stuff but it was yeah it
was a
straight off the edge and and that was
me i thought how long how long were you
no break
rolling down the hill difficult to tell
i think probably
10 seconds i mean the driver was trying
to bounce it against the wall to slow it
down
but you can imagine these roads it's
just a dirt track sheer
sheer sort of rock face on the one hand
and then a drop
off no no barriers nothing like that and
it was just a completely pitch of
pitch black middle of the night uh
and that was it i thought it was i
thought i was a goner and um
it was almost comedic in the sense that
it it didn't it literally
flew off the edge and we were airborne
for what felt like an eternity it was
probably just a few seconds but it was
the only part of
the uh the roadside where there were no
trees because it was forested this this
bank
um but we went off the bit where there
was obviously a river running through so
it just kept on going and when we
finally did hit the deck it
bounced and rolled and probably rolled
10 times all the way to the bottom of
the valley
and somehow i stayed in the vehicle the
driver and
this random other um guy that he'd
picked up a local
had been thrown through the windscreen
somewhere up on the mountain we stayed
in the car
and yeah made it all the way to the
bottom
at which point i thought i'd lost my arm
because i couldn't feel it or see it
um i managed to when the car settles
yeah when it finally settles are you
conscious consciousness
conscious the whole time yeah what do
you say to your brother
besides bro i'm sorry well you're out
here
it was i can thank my brother because
when i when i sort of figured out where
i was i crawled out the car thought i'd
lost my arm
my first instinct was to go find my arm
you know it's seen on the beach him
saving private ryan where he's looking
hold his arm looking slightly dazed and
confused
that was me in this car i went i
couldn't find it then i realized it was
still attached but i couldn't feel it it
was pointing the wrong way it was
completely i mean you can see the
score there um i had to sort of snap it
back into place that's when the pain
started and i think it was me screaming
that woke my brother up
and he was relatively uninjured i mean
he'd been bashed around but he hadn't
got anything broken so
i couldn't move i was in such pain binod
guide he was
pretty much unconscious and pete my
brother he
he came over and um you know he
he's done if he'd done a few trips but
nothing like this you know he he was
working in finance you know he sort of
he's back in finance yeah well no it's
the interesting thing was pete rescued
us he went and shouted for help luckily
the
sound of the car crashing had woken up
some local villages a mile away and
they'd come to investigate
probably took about an hour maybe for
enough locals to come to carriers out
but then they had to carry us a mile
through the jungle to the local village
were you you weren't bleeding uh i mean
you might i wasn't bleeding
you weren't like bleeding bleed like you
weren't life-threatening blood no it was
just my arm was just
completely mangled um the the driver
sadly was in a very different position
he'd broken
everything his body his neck as you know
he was somewhere in the mountains
instead to go and find him
we were taken to a very small clinic in
the local village and when i say small i
mean there's like chickens running
around the water this was basic stuff um
but luckily there yes that qualifies as
basically when you roll into the
hospital and there's chickens
they um but they had morphine thankfully
so that that
you know took away some of the pain but
yeah my brother he
he coordinated the rescue it took three
days though because it was a rainy
season we couldn't get a helicopter in
the roads were all washed away
um so it took three days for helicopters
to come so it was a it was a trying time
to say the least and i think my brother
was possibly regretting his uh
his holiday distinction but um but yeah
he he was a real trooper throughout
the whole experience and um yeah so that
that that really
disrupted the trip a little bit but i
had to fly back to the uk for surgery
because they couldn't do it in kathmandu
because it was just after the
2015 earthquake which had screwed all
the hospitals
so i went back to the uk had surgery
they fixed my arm but then i couldn't
give up this was my i chosen this this
was my career i wasn't going to give up
so i
uh whatever it was 45 days later i flew
back out to nepal
went back to the car still there in the
jungle rusting over and carried on
walking for another three months
the tv show came out yeah they came out
they enjoyed that bit they like
they film me in hospital getting surgery
and all the rest of it and and then this
becomes
another tv show and did you write
another book about this yeah wrote a
book yeah called walking the himalayas
keep it simple and um and then they of
course they said what's next
so i had to come up with another one
you're paying yourself into a corner man
yeah absolutely
so what was the next one walking the
americas um
so i wanted to do something in central
america i'd had this girlfriend this
mexican girlfriend
who so i knew mexico quite well uh but i
was fascinated by
the ancient mayan civilization i wanted
to go to
see places like honduras and um
guatemala
and in colombia because i knew that
would have a bit of edge
and so i decided to walk from where the
spanish first landed
um in the yucatan peninsula give it a
bit of historical context
all the way to south america across the
darian gap
which um is probably one of the most
remote and fearsome stretches of jungle
anywhere in the world
so that was another six months another
2000 miles of walking
um again lots of scrapes there as well
and this is the same thing tv crews
coming out joining you for
four or five days here and there
wherever they think there's gonna be the
most
mayhem is when they're showing up you're
carrying a freaking backpack with like a
water bottle
yeah and 50 bucks
yeah yeah and off we went and um and
that that was a really that was actually
a really enjoyable journey because the
guy that came with me my guide for that
one was actually a guy who had known for
a number of years called alberto
who was the guy that got me into
photography in the first place and he'd
lived in mexico he'd never walked
anywhere in his life
anywhere and he certainly wasn't a
professional guide he was a studio
photographer he was
far more at home sitting on yachts with
supermodels but he
had just got divorced and was looking
for an adventure so i said look mate
come with me
we're going to go and have some fun and
off we went and we walked for um yeah
for six months through all these
random countries and we went through the
ganglands in honduras
met um you know the sort of the cartels
along the way we we've sort of had
meetings with all sorts of gangsters it
was that was a wild trip as well
what about a gopro i so i had this
little flip camera
the interesting thing is actually you'd
think sometimes that it'd be tricky to
film in these places but
actually having a camera does open up
conversations people are like
hang on i want my photograph taken or i
want you i want to tell you my story
and particularly in places that don't
get many tourists because if you go to
touristy places people
aren't they're not that interested in
getting the photos taken or or telling
you their story but if you go to
honduras i mean there's one
one story from there we were in um a
town called san pedro sula
which other than sierra dwaras i think
was the murder capital of the world this
is where
the two main cartels you've got
ms-13 and barrio 18 these two rival
gangs that do
pretty bad things to each other um are
based
they they've got their own you know
neighborhoods
and we wanted to walk straight through
the city and the only way to do so was
to cross between these two gang lands
but of course the police and the army
were like look we don't go in there
you can't rely on us for backing so we
asked around and alberto was sort of
doing all the translation and we
eventually found this street pastor who
said look i know
the gang leaders are both of these guys
i can probably get you in if you want so
okay well
ask the question so he got his he got
two phones out actually
and he called the leaders of both gangs
and had them on speakerphone
next to each other which is bizarre both
of these leaders were both in jail
right because they were and
he got them if they were and he got them
both on speakerphone and said look i've
got these two
two gringos i mean he wasn't melbourne
who's a mexican but he called us both
grigor he said look
they want to walk through your through
your turf um
you know will you let them and um to my
surprise these both these leaders like
yeah absolutely no problem you know as
long as you give a fair
and honest representation of of of our
story we want to tell you our story and
why we
have these gangs but he said just give
us 24 hours because we're just going to
clean up the graffiti
and pick up the trash from the streets
they wanted to show the best side of
their gang wars
and it was the most bizarre experience
but we went through these these areas
escorted by these kids 10 12 year olds
we're covered in tattoos with with
pistols down their jeans
and they showed us the casa lokas the
crazy house where they torture each
other and
they should the idea this is where we
killed you know this person this is
where we
hung it was like tragic stuff but in the
most surreal setting and it was it was a
very
bizarre experience to go and see that
and we saw a guy shot at the side of the
street you know just in
just yeah from these gang wars so
and and i'm not into voyeurism i don't
go there to sort of
glamorize any of this it's trying to
show what
you know what the struggle is like for a
lot of people living in these
circumstances and
and not shy away from some of those
really difficult
but compelling stories now did you did
you have a film crew there when you did
that section
they they had come out and and we had a
real struggle with the channel
to to sort of allow us to go into these
places because
you can imagine the lawyers back home
it's like oh this is this is too sketchy
we're not sure about this
plus people with brains back home bro
but you know i think a lot of it was
down to the fact that we got we found
this guy who he wasn't a cowboy
he was like i live i've lived in these
in in on this
on in these neighborhoods all my life
and so did the camera come crew come
through or not so they cut yeah
they did yeah so all that footage and so
what's that what's that show called
walker
walking the americas walking the
americas and how many hours is one of
these
series each one's i mean the nile was
four episodes four hours
himalayas was five i think walking in
america was five as well
yeah okay so now you get back from that
and you got to step it up again right
okay so the next one
basically this is what you're getting
into going back to my sort of original
point of going back to places that i'd
studied
my studies at university have mainly
been about um you know the middle east
about places where
the old british empire had a legacy or
places in you know in the news now
current affairs and obviously
um russia iran were both pretty
high up on the agenda this was back in
2017 putin's sort of just getting
reelected all this sort of stuff so i
wanted to go and explore that region
more the caucasus
as a historical region is fascinating so
i thought why not do a journey
from europe into asia over the caucasus
mountains from russia into iran
we called that one crossing the wild
frontier so we started on the black sea
finished on the caspian sea and going
through places like chechnya
dagestan azerbaijan georgia and then
finished in iran
getting travel permits to go into those
places was was actually quite tricky but
you know we had to apply to russia and
the first thing they ask on your
visa application is have you or have you
ever served in a foreign military so
they dig deep into your background but
thankfully
they you know they let me in the same
with iran i mean getting into iran was a
tricky one because
initially they were like no way we don't
let you know especially
from from the uk we're not friends right
now
um eventually through a contact
i was told that i could meet a person
from the iranian
embassy but not at the embassy it was
just very mysterious lady who wouldn't
give me her name
with sunglasses met me in a cafe in in
south kensington and london
and said what do you want i said there's
a link to all my shows go and see for
yourself
i gave her a copy of my books and
she said okay i'll go ahead and read
them and the next day i
it was on the president on you know the
president's or prime minister's desk of
around
and i got approved of visa and i think
what they liked is the fact that i'm
i'm not there to deal on propaganda but
i'm not shying away from
the hard stories either but i'm not i'm
certainly not there to do investigative
journalism to
with an agenda-based sort of approach
i'm there to show what life is like for
normal people
and and they let me in and so i did this
amazing trip
through places that you would you just
don't get a fair
understanding of especially places like
chechnya
and and that was a really really
fascinating journey thankfully
nothing went particularly wrong on that
one i just got a really great
understanding of what what the region
was like
yeah and i think um you know a lot of
times when people ask me you know i was
just asked this i was getting
interviewed the other day
and you know people started asking about
well
the war in iraq should we have been
there and all this was it
is it the moral right thing to do and a
lot of times what i
try and do in those situations is i try
and bring things down to a very granular
level of what it was like on the ground
and what i what i like about what you're
what you're doing is you're going
be i guess the word is beneath the
politics i don't know if that's going to
sound right but
you're going beneath the political
atmosphere to the actual other human
beings
that are living their lives that are you
know trying to earn a living trying to
raise their family trying to
build their future and there's so much
commonality that gets missed
and that's that's often what i also say
about iraq you know it's like i would
kick in the door to a building and
there'd be you know a family in there
and they
dad's trying to build a business of
selling whatever dates and
the mom's you know trying to sell stuff
that she can sell in the neighborhood
and the kids are wanting to play soccer
and they're just normal people and yet
you can never
you can never see that when you when
it's all screened out by the political
viewpoint so
what i what's is clicking for me now and
i'm starting to understand is that
you're going beneath
that level and talking to the people
on the ground and getting a real look
and probably i'm assuming
exposing all these commonalities that we
have as human beings with
other human beings yeah and i mean that
was never
an outright intention i it's just sort
of happened throughout these journeys is
is trying to find out what
what does unite us and actually trying
to find those human stories and actually
there's a lot of positivity and what
i've found is
the sense of hospitality you know has
been
overwhelming throughout and and that
i've seen that in
in some of the places that you wouldn't
expect it yeah and even even you know i
started off
joking in the early part of this you
know no one would ever invite me in
their house and then
as i'm sitting here listening to you
talk and i've been to i mean obviously
i've been all over the world and been to
all kinds of different countries and
it's the same thing when you actually
when you actually get past that get
underneath that political
um vision that we have of a place
there's you know i've had people treat
me
unbelievably well all over the world and
that's why you have to get you have to
you have to make those
human connections with other people and
you'll realize oh yeah
they'll help you out i mean like you
said most people
they'll give you some water if you need
some water they'll pull over the side of
the road and help you if you need it
that's
ab absolutely so that's that's uh very
enlightening
i'll never forget when i was on the nile
this was back in 2014
i was in sudan and it was this was a bit
with there's no
crew there it was it was me with with a
local guy called moes
and it was getting very hot we couldn't
carry enough water just to survive so we
had to go and buy some camels from the
local market
now i don't know how to keep a camel you
know keep a camel going so we thought
we'd better employ a couple of bedouin
camel handlers to come with us
so for two months we trekked across the
entire sahara following the river nile
there was one bit of the nile where um
we had to go sort of
slightly into the desert because there
was some security issues by the um
by the nile so we were going through
these villages and everyone was so
hospitable people were saying come in
have a you know
have some of our water and it was almost
it was so overwhelming we were getting
slowed down because we needed to reach
the egyptian border
um before ramadan because that was that
was the basis for which these two camel
handles said that we'll come with you
but only for 50 days because we're going
to get back to our families so we that
was the deadline that was the hard stop
so off we went and we were getting
further and further behind schedule
because
of the hospitality because people say oh
come and teach my kids english and
this and the other so we my two
camel handlers were on the verge of
revolt at this stage today
we're gonna we're going home if you're
gonna you know mess around doing your
silly filming and this stuff so we came
to an agreement we said okay what we'll
do is day on day off we'll
one day we'll go through the villages
where we'll meet people and talk and
film and this you know
all that and then we'll do another day
walking in the desert avoiding the
villages
and camping out in the desert and
thereby we can cover more ground
but there was one occasion where we'd
done this we're in the middle of the
desert
about a mile away from the nearest
village we set up our our camp
made a little fire and the local
villages a mile away must have seen the
flickering of the flames
in the desert and it wasn't long before
a crowd of men came and
came out to investigate they said what
are you doing and we said well
we explained that we were trying to
avoid their hospitality in the most
polite terms possible and they said they
were getting really upset by this i know
you must come
and we said no one guy stormed off and
he came back
half an hour later he carried his bed on
his head and he said if you're not going
to come into my house
my home is coming to you and that i
think really demonstrates the the
incredible hospitality i can't remember
i can't ever imagine that happening back
in london if a sudanese man was sort of
passing down the street but
it's it's moments like that that really
do kind of restore your faith in
humankind
but you still have to step it up a
little bit it seems like we're just
getting
we're just getting more and more hostile
environments and so now it's like 2017
the freaking war in iraq and syria with
isis is just
flaring up flaring up so of course
you're like a moth drawn to the fire
so that's the next one right so i'd
always been fascinated by the middle
east like i mentioned
before i in 2003 i was in iraq um
i like the way you kicked these stories
off with like i've always been
fascinated with
you know how sharp a shark's teeth could
be
all right so you got this fascination
with the middle east so i've been there
in 2003 which is when i hitchhiked
through baghdad and all this
you know so i wanted to return to
to iraq and wanted to see more of the
region ever since and i
actually in fact after the nile i
pitched the idea of doing a trip around
the arabian peninsula
to the powers that be within tv and
sadly they said no they said
one it's probably too dangerous and two
they didn't feel as though
there was sufficient interest they said
in fact the word the exact words were
that's just the realm of current affairs
and news nobody nobody's interested in
the middle east as a destination it was
a place to find out more about i thought
that was just a disappointing
answer so euron i'd pitch this you know
after the himalayas i pitched it again
they said no let's do the americas
after that i pitched it again they said
no again and that just wound me up
so after the rush into iran expedition i
was like i am doing the middle east i
want to go to
arabia come on may we're the way out you
so i pretty much
you know got told no we're not doing it
by by the tv company by the tv guys and
um i said well i'm doing it which didn't
didn't go down well in tv land in the uk
but i decided that was that problem so i
set up my own production company to
facilitate this would you say tv people
these are
this is the channel this is the channel
this is the channel and and
you're pitching that is it multiple
channels that you're pitching to as well
no this is just like
straight up it wasn't the bbc it was it
was channel four
yeah um they but you know it then got
syndicated out to discovery channel and
whoever else wants to buy it
internationally so you're pitching
to the people that have made your other
shows hey let me do this one
and they're like look no no not
happening and you just say all right
cool i'm doing it anyways yeah
so i wouldn't say i got sacked but i
kind of
they said okay well you're not working
with us if that's the case so i said
okay that's fine i'm gonna go and do it
so i set up my own production company
and basically self-financed this
expedition with a couple of mates my
friend dave and simon who chipped in
and going back to that thing about
empowering people and bringing people on
the team i said look if we all chip in
the same amount of cash
we'll take the same amount of profit at
the end of the day and they said okay
and these are guys who'd help me
before on shows doing the health and
safety and i got neil my god
my mate who's the director to come on
board so we basically just clubbed
together and off we went and actually it
freed up
so many things because i was getting
more and more frustrated with
more and more restrictions and
limitations on how things were produced
and actually
i felt like my creative sort of my
personal creative spirit was being
somewhat suppressed a little bit so i
said okay i'm gonna
give this a go what's the worst that can
happen so we decided to go and just do
this and and the idea was to go and
look at the arabian peninsula and all
the countries that that make that up
um in the same way not necessarily
walking the whole route this time
because there's a lot of
empty empty stretches of desert where
not much goes on but but certainly
hitchhiking and
and traveling with locals so the plan
was to start up on the turkish border
with with syria up in
java and the kurdish region and
basically
walk travel hitchhike whatever all the
way around the entire
gulf and then finish up at lebanon in
the historic city of biblos which is the
oldest
city in the world and revisit some of
these places i'd been to on my earlier
travels
including baghdad and to create mosul
now of course this was in the
in the height of the war against isis
they still weren't defeated in
syria and iraq um so it was a pretty big
challenge
um but doing it very light footprint it
was only there's only other three of us
traveling at once
we it meant that we could actually go
and achieve something that had never
been done before which is
actually travel through all these
multiple countries so
going through places like syria were
embedded with the
the kurdish militia um in iraq
we managed to join a group called the
hashid
um the the pmf the popular mobilization
forces who are
sometimes the bad guys but these are the
guys fighting against isis
on this occasion but they're also
iranian-backed militias
i was embedded with them on the final
hawija offensive which is the final
battle against isis in iraq
um on the front line i mean that was
that was something else i mean it was
it was an entire afghan tour in three
days i mean it was
it was intense um so now you guys are
now you guys are the camera crew
just three of us yeah so now you got
cameras rolling all the time and i
watched some of your
some of the stuff that's on youtube i
watch you rolling up to that
offensive and the guy's like all right
lunch break and
there's some you know having worked with
the iraqi soldiers a bunch i was like
i know what's going on there i know what
that feels like yeah um
uh but but like what was
what was the proximity to the fighting
there were you getting right in it
yeah i mean it was it was a it was kind
of a bizarre experience because we
managed to hitch a lift to the front
line
where these sort of uh that you know the
the iraqi volunteers these weren't the
iraqi army these were literally the guys
too old or too young to join the
to join the military and they were
fighting on their home turf they were
fighting their neighbors so these were
mainly sheer
militiamen fighters who'd volunteered
mainly to come out of retirement to
basically
go you know kick isis off the off the
off the land
so we were rolling up not i mean they
had about 12 main battle tanks but
mostly these guys were in flip-flops and
toyota
pickups you know with a 50 car mounted
on the on on the back and
driving in a straight line no no tactics
no strategy literally a taxi to the
front line
so we got a taxi to the front line said
we'll drop us off here hitch to ride on
a tank just jumped on a tank and just
drove
the main the point vehicle was a
bulldozer with this iraqi dude with a
cowboy hat
i mean it was absolutely crazy yes
smoking a cigar
as the bullets were pinging off the
front of this bulldozer and it was just
a straight line waiting to get ambushed
and we got ambushed and
you know you could see the black flags
of isis in these villages and we just
drive up to them
spread out bond the [ __ ] out of it and
then go in there and we were
in the mix you know right on the front
line filming everything and um
liberating these villagers and them
capturing ice we caught three isis
commanders
i mean i've still got i've still got one
of the flags at home actually that i
took with me
um but it was it was quite it was it
felt
a very important and historical moment
you know these when when the villagers
were liberated and they caught
the command the isis uh fighters the
women would come out they'd rip their
burqas off and they were thanking these
iraqi volunteers for rescuing them some
of these women hadn't
been outside of their own compound for
three years
so it was it was it was a very powerful
thing to to be witness to
yeah we had a another gaston and covered
another book on here
holly who whose book only cry for the
living and
she interviewed a lot of those women and
what they went through
so you know liberation was
the the understatement of the year for
what was happening
to the people inside those villages that
were
you know and cities that were were run
by isis
um did you what are you you're not
i know that you don't carry a weapon
when you do this stuff
um were you just wearing body armor we
we managed to pick up some body armor
from her bill
you know just bought some from the local
shop and and on off you go but
um yeah going through
the sort of the urban fighting in place
like shark at i mean we were in mosul
this was a week or two after it had been
liberated from isis i mean you know
there's there was still a lot of clear
operations going on um you've obviously
got to be careful
but you know i've been doing this for
long enough to know what to do and what
not to do but at the same time we wanted
to we wanted to see what was going on
because nobody was filming this you know
the only news reports that were coming
out were coming out from baghdad or
building very few people getting onto
the front line and actually seeing
what life is like on both sides you know
and we we we met these isis fighters
we got a camera in their face and um
that that was quite rare
so it was it was fascinating to to see
what was going on and to see the the
reality of life and
and these guys the the volunteers who
were fighting they'd been fighting
solidly for three years so you mentioned
the lunch break i mean
literally in the middle of the battle
the the the truck turned up with with
the chicken sandwiches on on the back
and and people just
stopped they're like well this the
fight's not going anywhere and everyone
just sat down
and and had the chicken sandwich and
then carried on and it was it was quite
a
bizarre experience but it's no different
than being on exercise and saws will be
playing with the british army really
uh as you as you wrap
up um getting like how did you how did
you decide it's time to move on was it
when
was it like missoula was now pretty much
done was it what what made you decide
all right we can we can move on now
so on the last day i mean we'd been
attached with these guys
we'd seen mosul we'd been attached to
the to the to the to the frontline
fighting units for for a couple of days
there was one guy i mean it kind of it
it all sunk in i mean one we we kind of
got enough fighting footage and we
didn't want this show to be entirely
about the fighting but but two i meant
this one
guy um we've been told we must meet him
his name was abu tassin
now abu tassin his nickname was the
hawkeye he was iraq's most feared sniper
he'd been fighting he was 65 years old
he'd fought in every war
since 1973 against the israelis he'd
fought in bosnia and chechnya
he'd fought in 91 and in the gulf
against
you know the americans he'd fought in
2003 against the british in basra he'd
fought in 2007
against you probably in in in iraq
um in fallujah rather and um and he come
out of retirement
to fight against isis because he is she
a guy he's a sheer guy
yeah and he was literally iraq's most
feared warrior i mean they've been books
written about him and he was there
fighting on his motorbike with his
big you know six-foot sniper rifle
and he he agreed to speak to me he
didn't normally do journalist interviews
particularly
with with brits that's for sure um but
he agreed to speak to me
sort of soldiers or soldier when i sort
of told him i was in the in the paris
and he said well i've you know
probably killed some of your friends as
long as you don't mind that and it was a
big
decision to go and sit with this guy who
had been
not my personal enemy but enemy against
my colleagues and friends
but you kind of have to take that
emotion out of it
and ultimately i was in his country
listening to his story
um and by the way now he was fighting
against an enemy
yeah so he was the british
and of humanity sure so
we were sat around the campfire and he
told me a story he killed 400 odd people
um he was quite open about the fact that
he was against
you know us the coalition invading his
country but
we were on the the right side of history
this time around and he he thought that
what he was doing was the right thing
which was
to rid his land of isis which he was
convinced was a creation of
the the the chaos of of you know ten
years of war
and i think it was that moment i thought
okay enough enough i've heard
i've heard the story we should move on
and it was probably about time actually
because
sadly seven days later he was himself
killed by isis
on that same battle on the last day of
the war against isis
so there was some sad poetry in that but
um
we left we left that behind and carried
on the journey and
continued around the gulf and um and
like i said i didn't want
this journey to be just about the
conflict because that's what we
associate so much with
with the region um but to then jump out
of iraq and then be
in in southern iraq actually we were in
in amongst the the marshes around
nasseria and basra
you know this is the birthplace of
civilization garden of eden
and so on and to be in amongst the the
marsh arabs i don't know if you serve
down there with with these
these these very traditional tribes
um who literally you know live amongst
the marshes in these
in these ancient um ways of living in
the huts
and they're called the mud heath and uh
you know
fishing and farming buffalos i mean it's
like going back to biblical times and it
was
that stark contrast you know um which
was to me
really really interesting and i wanted
to give that balance and then to go from
there into q8 and then to the to
to dubai where you suddenly got these
skyscrapers and um
friday boozy brunches i wanted to show
that whole spectrum of what life is like
in in this region and
it was some really stark contrast and to
get your head into that and around that
was
was often quite difficult i mean dubai
is just crazy
it's crazy like especially when you talk
about that contrast
yeah between mosul completely destroyed
and
just a living hell for everyone that's
up there and then you go to dubai
which is just i mean it's sodom and
gomorrah yeah the entire city's been
built
for like 20 years or something like that
and it's just everything is
brand new and to the highest standards
of luxury
in everything it's like of it's you
can't get more of a start contract it
was a huge one i mean i actually quite
enjoyed going
and and it was a nice break having been
in on this war zone for the for the
yeah you probably got confused when you
saw like a bed
um but that's what i wanted to show i
wanted to show these these really stark
differences
and this traditional way of life the
bedouin you know i i
studied all about lawrence of arabia and
the old sort of arabist explorers people
like wolf wood thessider who
crossed the empty quarter and um so to
then go from there
into oman which is a beautiful country
you've got these
amazing endless sand dunes and very
traditional way of life there and then
into yemen again a country that
um was incredibly difficult to get into
but we somehow managed it
um it was yeah shown a fair
representation
you get done with this trip and then you
go back so how long does it take when
you get done with the trip how long does
it take for
the production to have happen and then
what did you do in this particular case
did you now have to sell what you made
exactly yeah so
with this one you know i've got my own
team on the case so we were editing
on the go i mean we're kind of sending
the rushes back and then we got
it you know got an edit suite and we
were doing on on the go so i think it
ended up being
i think we got back from the trip in
february march and it was it was on tv
sort of
two or three months later who did you
did you go back to channel four they
would say
no they they wouldn't take it though
they said principles
but we sold it to discovery channel in
the uk oh and then like
what and then it got it got shortlisted
for a broadcast award so
yeah that was that was a real sense of
uh
not just vindication but you know it was
it was a very very good documentary
and for me it took it back to the the
organic authentic roots of of what my
journeys
ultimately are is that one also like
four or five hours four or five shows
yeah that one's five episodes as well
were you profitable did you make money
we it washed its face just about
we didn't make that much money on it but
it was worth it just because
it set the ball very very high
so you get done with that one how do you
measure success on those
in terms of i mean is it view like hey
uh
a youtube video gets whatever a million
views
how are you judging success or if it's
hitting the people right
or is it just feedback from people
telling you hey that was outstanding i
never
understood the middle east like that now
i do thank you is it
how are you getting your your
gratification so for me the validation
it's not just about ratings because
obviously that's a lot to do with
the the media landscape and the current
politics of what's going on
it's changed enormously just in in the
seven or eight years that i've been
doing this
you know in terms of tv wise um you know
it's changed enormously with with you
know the amount of
streaming platforms out there the sheer
you know
just difference in demographics so
people aren't watching tv live anymore
they're watching on their laptops
they're watching on their mobiles so
and there's so many new new s faults out
there anyway so it's very difficult to
sort of gauge in terms of ratings a lot
of the
streaming platforms don't even publish
their viewing figures so
i don't think from and that for me was
never really uh as important as just
doing what felt authentic um and true to
my own
belief really and if there's a bit of
feedback that's good and positive then
great i mean i've you know
of course when you go to controversial
places you're going to get a bit of
flack from
different groups you know you didn't
show my tribe and what we do or
especially if you go to like the whole
israel-palestine question or if you're
traveling in somewhere like iran you
know it's difficult it's difficult to
tell everyone's story you're never going
to succeed in that
but for me it was actually the the
slightly
um indirect feedback when when you get
the head of a charity
saying thank you you know we've been
trying to put our country
on the map for the last 20 years and
just
one of your episodes has doubled our
revenue or something like that or you
get individuals who call you and say
you inspired me to quit my job in
finance and and
and you know go and build a clinic in
nepal or whatever it might be and as a
result
you know i've personally been asked to
to be an ambassador for
probably hundreds of hundreds of
charities i'm i'm currently ambassador
for about 20 or so charities and and
it's things like that that make it all
worthwhile for me so i'm not really that
bothered about the ratings obviously
it's nice to get good feedback and it's
nice to keep getting asked to do these
journeys but it's hard now to
do bigger and better when i feel as i've
kind of done most of the journeys that
i've
really wanted to so i'm just trying to
think about i've like how do i diversify
or stay true to my
true to my sort of core beliefs um
but also still enjoy what i'm doing and
still have fun and and
and uh yeah try and find something
that's that's
appropriate and and useful did the so
the next one was walking with the
elephants is that right sure did that
come after that came after yeah
so eventually they came back they came
back with us sort of saying oh can you
make another one for
so you kind of won strategically so i
won in the end i guess in that way so
um yeah they came back and said we want
to we want to do something else and
i've always been fascinated by
conservation once again there he goes
again
i've always been fascinated by
conservation so i was wondering
um elephants have always been my thing
um when i was 10 years old i sort of um
i don't been begging my parents to take
me to kenya to go and see elephants and
they couldn't afford it because they
were teachers but eventually they did
when i was i think i was 14
and it was mind-blowing you know seeing
africa the big skies the savannahs the
wildlife so
i had always wanted to try and
incorporate a sort of an element of of
giving back in all my expedition so i
always pair with a charity or raise an
issue i'm a high net worth
what's called a high a high profile
supporter
for unicef so i do i do a bit of work
with sort of
children's charities along the way um
but conservation is is something that
i think is really important not just for
the sake of the animals but but habitat
um keeping wilderness areas wild
and so i thought by going back to africa
particularly botswana in this case
um there's a real opportunity here to
to showcase what's happening in the
natural world and by doing one of my
sort of
walks through a country but this time
following a
heard of elephants on the ancient
migration route there's a new way of
telling this story
so i was walking with a heard of
elephants for 650 miles across botswana
all the way to the okavango delta um how
many elephants
well there's 120 000 in botswana how
many were you walking with
i mean it just depended on the day
really but we were getting pretty close
to
some pretty big groups like 10 or like a
hundred no it could be 30
50. yeah it's probably 50 was the
maximum we saw at any one did you get to
know some of them
you get to know the some of the
personalities yeah especially when
they're flapping their ears and chasing
after you yeah
but i mean it was a really really
intense experience because
you're when you're in an alien
environment
on the one hand that you know you're on
you're on your guard the whole time
you've got to watch out because at any
time not just from the elephants but
you know a snake might when you're when
you're sort of out taking a dump of a
snake might come and bite you on the ass
or whatever it might be
you've got to be really careful we were
camping the whole time staying
inside the national parks we got a very
we we were sort of greeted with them
by the botswana government with with the
utmost respect because they said look
you know not only encouraging tourism
but showcasing the botswana such a
tourism a conservation success actually
and and so we were able to camp inside
these national parks
and and really get to know the wildlife
but
i'd say that as human beings coming from
africa that's what we're designing we're
meant to be
you know in that natural environment so
it did feel like a very natural journey
as well
and that was that was the last big trip
that you took
that brings us up the current date
pretty much that was in the summer of
last year doesn't count because it
covered
so so yeah that kind of brings us up
today on on the sort of big journeys
really
so that's probably probably a pretty
good place to stop other than to say
so what your latest book that's about to
come out is the book that i've been
referring back to some
somewhat today the art of exploration so
what what
what made you decide you need to get
another because this is like what we
what did we say was your ninth book this
is my this is number nine um
for the last 12 months having been
somewhat locked up has given me plenty
of opportunity to reflect on
some of the stories that i didn't put in
my other books and
i wanted to sort of i guess
give some of the lessons that i've
learned personally but not just that it
lessens from other explorers from other
key leaders and and reflect back on my
time in
in the army as well so it really it's
it's a bit of a summing up
uh for me of the last sort of 10 15
years really of of the lessons that i've
learned and i've tried to
put them into relevant themes and make
them applicable and
relevant to people in their daily life
so it's not just me telling
telling my war stories this is some of
the stories hopefully will will inspire
people to to to hopefully you know
integrate them into their own lives
yeah i don't think i did a great job of
what i selected to read in terms of the
fact that
you you're you you're kind of given your
philosophy much
throughout much of the book and you're
explaining you know what lesson you
learned but
you know here's how i learned the lesson
then you explain well this is what the
lesson was and this is how you can apply
it so
it's a it's a philosophical book as well
not just like you said a book i read
stories
i read a lot of stories i like to read
stories but and you know some of them i
said here's some of the leadership
lessons that you learned and i pointed
out the
the way that you lay those out so that
people can and you
it's not just about leadership though
it's about decision making you've got a
whole section in there about
how you sort of lay out decision making
based on your military
education and what so there's all kinds
of
things that you can pull from this book
and
they're all rooted in what you've been
through which is again
that's what my all my books are just hey
this is what i've been through and
here's
what i took away from it so you did this
exact same thing and
and anybody that's listening you're
gonna
you're gonna pull a lot of lessons out
of this book
um i scratched the surface i read less
than five percent of this book
on the air today so uh pick up the book
it's freaking yeah i mean it's just just
chalk
as you would say in england it's chock
full of lessons learned
um where can people find you i know you
got levisonwood.com
what's levison it's it's a family name
right it's my that was my dad's name and
his dad's name
like it's just stuck with me i'm the
fifth yeah
but yeah i know people can find out more
about it on my instagram page
uh levison.wood i've got twitter um
and yeah the new book is coming out in
june in the uk
and hopefully it will be out in the us
shortly after yeah
we need to get the pre-order on amazon
yeah by the way yeah
like you got about two weeks from today
to make that happen okay uh echo charles
yes any questions from anything else
uh remember when you lost your wallet
remember
do you think if you didn't lose your
wallet you would not have
gone into the military when you think
about it
i think that you know the when i lost my
wallet the inspiration you know the main
lesson that i learned there
was kind of told by this young
lieutenant who found it
was go and travel and and perhaps if i
hadn't have traveled if i hadn't have
got those expert early experiences
if i hadn't have had the gun pulled on
me by the guy in the taxi in zimbabwe
then maybe i wouldn't have enough
stories to get me through the interviews
that got me into the army so
who knows i mean hindsight is obviously
a great thing but but yeah i think
you know take opportunities when when
they come
come along um say thank you
to to people you know you never know be
courteous and it's it's it's
you know writing back to that guy and
just saying thank you for
handing all it back you know got me all
those tips in the form of that six page
essay so it's just little things like
that it's just it's
never passed by an opportunity and never
passed by an opportunity to to be
thankful and grateful
and no matter how bad things get there's
always an opportunity in that and so
like when i broke my leg and couldn't
get in the special forces i now look
back and join the dots and think
actually it was that
it was that what i thought was a low
point actually was a real opportunity
to go and do something different yeah
yeah that's crazy huh because
on the surface you're like dang i lost
my wallet because that sucks
confirm you lose your wallet oh man
brutal
and then yeah man it opens up this whole
thing and it's like dang i'm kind of
glad i did lose my wife yeah of course
and he's having a bit of faith that
in every situation now whenever i'm
feeling oh you know dammit that that's
gone really badly i remind myself of all
the times that
the bad situations if you just view them
right and have the right attitude
then then you can turn defeat into
victory and i think that's what you've
got to remind yourself so whenever
things go really badly i try and just
convince myself even if it's slightly
delusional
that this is a great opportunity
absolutely true man absolutely true well
like i said
probably a good place to wrap we're
approaching three hours right now
uh thanks for joining us absolutely and
and more important
thanks for your service
thanks for your service to uh great
britain one of our
maybe our most maybe our strongest ally
um
not only for your service but your your
fathers and your grandfathers i know i
watched a video about your grandfather
and
man was just awesome that that he was
out there like you
holding the line against tyranny and
evil
and thanks for sharing some of your
stories
thank you like i said there's 10 books
i always try and prepare i couldn't read
10 books getting ready for this thing
um a ton of great stories and and the
lessons that you
you share and the experiences
allow all of us to learn
through your vicariously
through your explorations of the world
which you've made the best of i don't
recommend them but i'm glad you did them
and i'm glad we can take away those
lessons man it's awesome awesome to meet
you man thank you thank you so much
thank you and with that
levison wood has left the building
he left the building he wasn't he didn't
have anything with him
so he may be going i don't know
he's going somewhere we don't know where
he came in we don't know where he came
from
we don't know where he's going but he is
out there
on the continual exploration yeah with a
pocket full of like uh you know two
paper clips
and his wallet a wallet that he found
and we're good so awesome to have him on
here for sure
we were talking about exploration that's
the name of his new book the art of
exploration
echo seems like exploration topic of the
day
can you recommend some ways we can
explore
getting better yeah as humans for sure
what do you got
so i think keeping ourselves capable
good call really you know look we have a
path
the path is hard not all the time but it
can be hard it's what i'm saying
every once in a while we can deviate
from that path but the best way to
deviate from the path
is when we explore if we explore as long
as it's in the right direction
don't slip off the path don't go
backwards
keep moving forward anyway so
while we're doing that we are improving
ourselves we are working out there's
certain fundamentals to the path we'll
see
for sure working out physical uh
improvement capability strength
the more i'd learn about strength and
strength training resistance training
you know this kind of stuff the more
benefits start to reveal themselves
yep did you know strength training
resistance training is
the best thing for your cognitive
capacity as you grow older yes
yeah i did did i say that last night you
did i remembered it why because i work
out
and for your immune system so you either
like i think you hold vitamin d
more efficiently or yes something with
vitamin d where you can
check you know anyway so cute so stay on
the path in that way anyway
through this path you might need
supplementation yes all right chocolate
supplements only the best kind
by the way yeah you probably need unless
you
are just dedicating 24 hours a day
for meal prep and you have you're you're
out shopping you're out harvesting your
own meat you're out
you're out in the garden pulling up
carrots
you know if that's what you're doing you
can probably get away without
supplementation
look we know that we want to eat clean
right if you're eating clean you don't
need it
the chances of that are pretty small
yeah they're pretty small
and again and there's a bigger picture
going on as well and
i am a huge advocate of garden i have a
small little miniature garden not many
things in there
we got some tomatoes in there either way
it's not about my garden all right
it's about efficiency apparently it is
about kind of a little
bit little humble brat just some
tomatoes
nonetheless uh you know
if you if gardening is your thing then
cool but
for a lot of us if you dedicate all
these hours
daily weekly whatever meal prep or
whatever
it might become a little inefficient so
supplementation
might be kind of the jam as far as
efficiency goes so good we've got some
supplementation for you
very good news so what do we got stuff
for your joints
stuff for protein stuff for cognitive
health stuff for general health
vitamin d3
joint warfare super clear oil we've got
some mole conditional protein
cold war cold war immunity immunity
immunity sure all these things aren't
choco fuel did you say punk
yeah protein in the form of a dessert
i authorized the next flavor of milk
what is that one it's gonna be that
banana cream oh yeah yeah
no name yet no name yet look and it's
hard to take banana cream and turn that
into something tactical
right so if anybody's got some ideas on
banana cream like
my my ears are open yeah i'm ready for
something cool
you know about banana cream let us know
what you got
that's interesting because that's not
like an obvious flavor but once you say
you're like
oh yeah that's a legitimate flavor yeah
even okay so the pumpkin spice in my
opinion this is just my opinion
because kind of an obvious flavor an
obvious flavor yes
but and i'm like not that into it it's
fine if that's my last flavor when we do
not drink it no probably not but
if when it comes to banana because i
don't like pumpkin pie you know certain
people like
really love pumpkin pie and that's it
nope
nope no anybody like that yeah i know a
couple people really yes
but are you sure bro are you
exaggerating you know someone that old
eats pumpkin pie if it's not for pumpkin
pie
you they won't eat any pie put it that's
where you're at right now okay so if i'm
not mistaken
i exaggerated a little bit but you know
what i mean it's fine say that
exaggerated a little bit but you know
what i'm saying because there's not one
single person on the planet that only
eats just pumpkin by 100
and the other pies are zero yes yes
there are pilgrims
pilgrims eat pumpkin pie that's all oh
wait i think they eat apple pies yeah
they do
anyway all right so cool the point is
banana cream pie that is a legitimate
one where it's like hey banana cream pie
and then there's like
everything else i'm one of those people
my dad's one of those people
there you go bc's in the game in the
game fully
so banana cream milk like that's
that's that's good yeah it's a good
flavor uh we also got the drinks
i'm drinking one right now i drink a lot
of these drinks as a matter of fact
discipline go in a can you can get it
you can get it at wawa
if you're on the east coast and for a
little while they were
there was a little break pumping going
on because the logistics train look
logistics wins wars
it took me a little bit of time to get
that logistics train straight down they
said
hey can you pump the brakes a little bit
guess what logistics train
is a moving down the tracks roll into
wawa
roll into wawa clear out the shelves
they didn't want me saying that for a
little while
yeah i'm back saying it going to wawa
clear off the shelves also vitamin shop
and by the way all this stuff all this
supplementation
if you want to subscribe to it if you
want to get that krill oil showing up
once a month you want to get that joint
warfare showing up once a month
if you want to go on subscription
shipping is free at originusa.com
at jockofuel.com subscribe get it
forever
and you know what we used to say on this
podcast
support the podcast as you support
yourself by the way you are supporting
the podcast when you support yourself
with some
supplementation no
yeah 100 and energy drinks
that are healthy that's kind of a thing
you know
well not really it's a thing with us
that's what i'm saying
it's not a thing with anybody else i'm
saying actually there's no one else that
said you know what oh we want our
we want our our energy drink to be
healthy so we are going to go to the nth
degree
and pasteurize it so we don't have to
put any chemicals in it
yeah that's where we went who else is
with us there oh look around you know
who i see
nobody yeah so it's not a thing it's a
thing for us that's what i'm saying it
is now
so what and you're talking even from
like a banking standpoint where it's
like yeah we're not gonna do that we're
not gonna do it
which is obviously good but as a human
being i don't
now i don't have to go hey i need some
energy hey i'm gonna pay the price a
little bit but i need that energy right
now say hey let's pay that
price you know there's no sacrifice no
sacrifice spell pound of energy drink i
don't i don't even need energy right now
i just want to drink that energy drink
and guess what i'm going to be more
healthy afterwards
when it comes down to it i'm going to be
more healthy
and i got my energy drink you're done
good you made up for your pumpkin pie
statement
there you go that's what we're dealing
with also at origin usa you can get
american-made
stuff when i say stuff i mean jeans
american-made dedham
kind of a big deal that's a real big
deal because you're probably thinking oh
you know i'm supporting america i got
these iconic american genes and then you
find out that your iconic american genes
are made in china
yeah which is bad yeah get your american
get your iconic american genes made in
america
yeah it's kind of alone in america sewn
in america you ever ate like a food or
something
and it says all natural then you find
out wait it's not all natural though
like i guess it's like they play all
natural cheese puffs
right come on bro it's like they play
you you know
where it's like it's all natural given
the fact that it's not all natural
you see insane it's almost like that
where it's like yeah these iconic
american genes oh yeah right and yeah
maybe they're like
so it just depends on what you mean by
all it depends on what you mean by
natural
it depends on what you mean by iconic
and it depends on what you mean by
american bro you're not playing that
game over here no
origin usa or usa is in the name
there's no play on words there's nothing
like that no trickery
made in america without compromising yep
jeans
boots rash guards t-shirts
what what else do you want yeah we got
it
yeah these did i say geez i think he
said rash guards but yeah all good it's
all included you said
we want to be inclusive yes inclusive
we're with you very much so we support
both also giaco has a store
it's called jacko's store this is where
you can get discipline equals freedom
stuff t-shirts hats hoodies
lightweight and heavyweight hoodies a
bunch of cool stuff on there in my
opinion so yeah go there
see if you like something get something
we also have a subscription situation
going on with the shirts
additional shirts additional designs
so recently one of the many designs that
have been
released so people have been calling me
personally calling me phone call not
text phone call
hey uh is that design
still available uh are you gonna sell
that design
it seemed like people really liked the
design it's true
the answer is maybe but to avoid
having to call me or whatever just jump
on that jump on that it's called the
shirt locker
yeah there's a new design every month
that reminds me of the muster so we have
the monster they always sell out
and three weeks out
from the muster like someone i know will
send me an email hey
i realized i didn't sign up for the
muster you know i it looks like it's
sold out but you know i just need three
seats
it's three and i'm like hey um
i i wish i could i wish i could help you
this is an actual limitation
like the fire marshal says this is how
many people can be in there
and we have it full filled
don't put yourself in that situation
yeah
at least don't put yourself in that
situation yeah it's true
maintain control yeah
invest up front so you can relax later
that's why you leave a little bit early
you leave a little bit early like you're
like i was supposed to meet you here
today
yeah right i left a little bit early
why did i do that so i wasn't stressing
i was just driving
oh there's a you know a little old lady
crossing the street she's taking a while
am i honking no i'm just take your time
ma'am no problem there's a construction
guy he's got the little sign flipping
you know
stop there's some road construction
going on am i mad at that guy
no i'm not mad at him i got plenty of
time to get to the gym
because you got on it early because i
got on it i invested early
now other people in this situation
didn't invest
i get a text once i'm here that says
yeah you're going to be late echo
charles is going to be late yeah
did you how do you feel about that uh
well you know
i was not stressing but hey that's just
me i guess okay maybe you need to add
some stress in your life then bro
well in this particular situation now
that you brought it up i didn't you did
and that's fine
so you know while i was executing my
sequence to uh come down here and record
okay all right i got tasked with the
last minute thing
and i had to do that i had to do that
thing so yeah
okay are you talking about a task that
came from me yes sir okay are you
talking about a task that came for me at
seven o'clock in the morning or such uh
well you know
my my sequence um is very complex your
wake up procedure
all right either way get on the
the shirt it's called the shirt locker
new shirt every month sean
jockowstore.com that's where you can get
it
go there get on it early you don't have
to worry about missing any any designs
or anything like that you can subscribe
to this podcast
there's a bunch of different places
where it's hosted
we also have jocko unraveling which i've
been recording with
daryl cooper we're going deep into some
crazy subjects
unraveling history and seeing where how
we got where we're at
we have the grounded pondcast we have
the warrior kid podcast we also have the
the underground
jockowunderground.com we're doing we're
recording a little podcast there
the reason that we're doing that is so
that we don't have to have
sponsors because why because we don't
want sponsors
because then they dictate what we can
and can't do which we don't like
we also don't want to have the platforms
themselves be able to dictate what we
can and cannot do
now look we the platform's been good to
us so far
everyone's been okay with what we're
doing that's fine what happens when
they're not
what happens when they decide they're
just going to take and start injecting
advertisements onto our podcast
and when i say all right i mean everyone
all of us
what do we do then we don't have control
so we made
we made the jocko underground podcast
jockowunderground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month
great way to support what we're doing if
you can't look if you can't afford it
where
look we are a podcast of the people
that's why this podcast is free that's
why this podcast doesn't have
advertising other than what we're doing
right now which you could have turned
off
48 minutes ago before echo even started
talking
but if you can't afford it that's cool
email assistants
jockowunderground.com we'll still hook
you up that's what we're here for we
have a youtube channel
where echo posts videos and you can
subscribe to that one
also origin usa has uh uh
oh what is it youtube channel is that
what it's called origin usa has a
youtube channel yes
technically at the end of the day but
it's like a series you know like you
have a youtube channel but a super
general
it's a general thing but there's like a
c
it's like a series you know that's
origin hd right that's a series
yeah that's that's what you're talking
about right yeah because origin hd is on
the youtube channel of origin
origin usa yeah boom okay well and echo
makes
a lot of those videos and the ones that
are really good are usually the ones i'm
the assistant director
all right psychological warfare yeah
it's an album
tracks you know you need jocko to help
you
get past the moment of weakness you're
kind of like a therapist in a way
or what do you call like a life coach
yeah it's a life coach you're a life
coach because you know how to coach with
a baseball bat
essentially no the life you know like
the life coaches the the what do you
call the classic
or the stereotypical situation is like
hey i'm about to
you know i just quit smoking and it's
like hey i feel like i really feel like
smoking it's really like you know on my
mind so you call your life coach
and they tell you gently like why you
shouldn't smoke you're gonna get cancer
so far and all this stuff so jocko has
his own version of that
which is called psychological warfare so
it's recorded what you do is you get
it's an album with tracks so jocko tells
you hey don't skip that workout
you've come this far you can do it um
need to make one of these
i was very motivated by that
[Music]
in his way we'll just say also we got
flipside canvas
flipsidecampus.com dakota meyer making
cool stuff to hang on your wall
we got a bunch of books look all the
books i talked about today
by levison wood the latest one
that should be available for pre-order
right now it's called the art of
exploration that's the one i was reading
out of today
we got final spin which is a
look it's a novel because it's not
specifically true
but it's also not a book it's like a
it's just a whole different gig final
spin
if you want it's new art form that's
what echo charles just whispered in the
background he might have nailed it
you might have nailed it is a new art
form
of writing and it's in a book called
final spin which is coming out
if you want to get the first a dish
better order it now
leadership strategy and tactics the code
the evaluation the protocol this one was
freedom field manual
way of the warrior kid one two three and
four mikey and the dragons about face
i wrote the forward on the new one and
of course
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership i have a leadership
consultancy
called echelon front we solve problems
through leadership
you can go to echelonfront.com if you
want me and my team to come and work
with your company that's what we do
we have ef online online
training leadership you can get it
anywhere you can get on your phone
we're on there all the time we're doing
live q and a's we got a bunch of courses
to take
it's freaking awesome we got the muster
we are executing last time we didn't
execute because i got miss rona
this time so i'm good now we're ha it's
happening orlando
may 25th and 26th phoenix august
17th and 18th las vegas october 28th and
29th
everything that we've done has sold out
go to extremeownership.com if you want
to come don't be
emailing me six days out
saying you need three hey sorry i didn't
get to you but i just need three seats i
can't i can't help you
sometimes in the seal teams i would tell
guys like hey if this
if you do if you make this mistake i
can't help you right
you want to do something like look you
do some dumb stuff i got you
if you do something at this level of
stupidity i can't
there's literally nothing i can do don't
be doing dumb [ __ ]
yes sir battlefield
uh this is learning lessons
as as we walk historical battlefields
just
did recently did gettysburg we're
planting others in the future
again go do go to echelonfront.com look
for events on there
if you want to come and and meet us you
won't have dinner you want to walk the
battlefield you want to do q and a face
to face
we look forward to seeing you at those
if you want to help service members
active and retire their families gold
star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee
she has a charity organization helping
out
all these groups all over the place if
you want to donate or get involved to go
to
america's mighty warriors
and if you want more of my
perpetual pronouncements or you need
more of echo's convoluted conversations
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter instagram which echo only
calls the gram
and facebook echoes that equal charles i
am at jockowink
and for levison check out
levisonwood.com
his twitter is levisonwood his instagram
is levison.org
and also he's on facebook at levesonwood
and thanks once again to levison for
for joining us again sharing some of the
stories with us
you could you could crack open any one
of those stories and find a gem
and and thanks to levison for your
service
and thanks to your father and your
grandfather
and to the fierce island nation of the
united kingdom thanks for standing
beside
us for so long in the fight against evil
and thanks to all the service men and
women
and veterans around the world that put
on the uniform and
shoulder the weight of freedom with your
service and sacrifice
and to people here at home in service
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol
secret service and all the first
responders out there you don't get
thanked enough
for what you do so thank you for doing
it
and everybody else out there
you already know what you know
you already know what you know you've
been there
you've done that you've seen what you've
seen
don't stay in the same spot
do like leveson wood does literally
and metaphorically go out
go go see go do
go live go explore
and until next time this is echo and
jocko